sorry members I really have to push you
now it's getting close to seven o'clock
and we we have to get started soon
are we ready members we're about to get
started
okay
good evening members and officers of the
council
I would like to welcome you to the first
meeting of the governance and audit
committee nice to meet some new people
this evening and see some people I've
known for a while
um before we dive into the agenda
there's a few bits of housekeeping but I
also have a couple of comments I wanted
to make from the chair
um as we have heard from the training
this is a really important committee we
have a duty as members to take this
quite seriously this is not overview and
scrutiny this is a governance and audit
committee I know we're going to work
together to fulfill our purpose I do
have some apologies to members to make
just I know there's been quite a bit of
disruption to the training apologies
there's been various cancellations we
just about got there I know there's also
been a couple of things with the agenda
I know a note was sent out today about
one of the tables and one of the agenda
items hadn't come across property format
hopefully everybody was able to access
the agenda and the final thing was we've
had a bit of back and forth you'll
notice that labor are down found one
member this evening because we've been
notified that cabinet members shouldn't
be sitting on governance and audits
there will be some changes with the
membership of the committee going
forward but just to explain some of the
changes
so going into the housekeeping side of
it if the fire alarm is activated please
vacate the offices via the stairs please
do not use the lifts assemble in Hawley
Square on the green officers will assist
you and advise you when it's deemed safe
to return to the chamber does anyone
intend to film this evening
okay it's a good sign
um would everyone please make sure that
their phones are turned silent they're
not used to make or receive phone calls
in the chamber while the meeting is in
progress
and please note that this meeting is
being live streamed for members of the
public the meeting will also be recorded
and will be subsequently broadcast on
the council's YouTube account
that is all of the formal notices I have
a couple more updates
first of all this is a big agenda for
this meeting and I know for quite a few
people this is your first governance and
audit committee so I know that there's
quite a lot to go through there's a
reason for that and throughout the
agenda we will go through that but I
just wanted from myself and from
Christian as Vice chair to thank the
officers for pulling this together I
think it was quite a feat to get
everything together
um
there's a couple of points that I think
is important
um I raise this chair before we get
started some people may notice that um
councilor Yates is in attendance
councilor Yates is intending to speak
under rule 20.1 on agendas uh items four
five and six I think it's an important
point to note because there has to be a
clear separation between the cabinet and
the governance and audit committee but I
would be eager and I know from speaking
to council Yates he would to hear what
members thoughts are on various agenda
items because most of these agenda items
relates to council yates's portfolio so
we are completely separate to make our
own decisions but as an opportunity to
potentially bring some of this closer
together so that cabinet can hear the
discussions that we are having I would
like to thank Council Yates for
attending I'm not sure he'll be at every
meeting but I wanted to reach out to him
second thing to say and I've spoken to
officers about it and I know I'm going
on a little bit at the start but we have
a massive agenda to get through
um Council constitutional rules are
quite clear that they apply to
committees any member introducing an
item or proposing a motion has five
minutes to speak anybody else in a
debate has three minutes and people
without unless the chair allows it can't
keep coming back and forth those are the
rules the reality is we want to be
flexible everybody wants to have their
say and ask questions but just because
we've got a lot to get through and I'm
sure we don't want to all be here till
midnight or 11 o'clock we will need to
make sure that we follow those rules of
debate where possible
so that is Enough from me
um for now so we're going to move on to
a gender item one which is apologies for
absence we have two apologies I'm aware
of we have councilor farooqi and we also
have a councilor packman
who are being subbed for by councilor
britcher and councilor Mata face are
there any other apologies
nope okay we'll move on to agenda item
two then Declaration of interest do any
members have a declaration that they
wish to declare
nope
okay we will move on to agenda item
three minutes of the meeting held on the
8th of March 2023.
um I will just make one point
um of the people who are on the
committee at the last meeting there are
only two surviving members uh which is
councilor towning to councilor Garner I
have spoken to them and said that as
they were the only ones present it
probably makes sense that they propose
and second because they can actually say
it was a true and accurate record but
before we get to that does anybody have
any questions or points on the minutes
councilor bright thank you chair
um being a geek I was watching the last
governance audit meeting
um and there was something that wasn't
covered in the minutes of the November
uh governance and audit meeting which
was around cash flow a cash collection
and parking enforcement is that coming
up in agenda item nine or ten
at all do we have a report on that
Chris do you have anything to so
um we've got within the quarterly
internal audit update report we've got
an update on car parking the order that
was done there and um we've got the head
of service that's for neighborhoods
Penny button with us who is responsible
for car parking he'll be able to give
the committee an update in terms of how
the service has progressed since that
intern or following Simon's update on
the matter
thank you okay can I have a proposer and
a second for the minutes
councilor town are you happy to propose
councilor Garner a second
our members agree that they're a true
and accurate record
yeah thank you very much
see we're whizzing for it we'll be done
in no time uh agenda item four external
Auditors audit finding reports I'm going
to pass over to Chris Blundell to
introduce this
thank you chat so um just before I pass
on to Nick Halliwell from Grant Thornton
who will lead on this item as Grant
Thornton have produced this report
this as I uh set out in the training
earlier on is
um Grant Fulton providing their
Assurance to you as the committee on the
work that's been done on our 2021
accounts there's a the the item at item
five is the actual accounts themselves
but it's important that you hear from
the Auditors themselves and you receive
that report before you consider the
account so that's why they've been
brought to you in this order the only
other thing I wish to bring to your
attention also offer an apology is that
there is a typo in the report in that in
the body report in the introductionary
section it relates to 1920 guilty as
charges rolling forward last year's
report where it actually does indeed uh
relate to the 2021 so um if it's okay
chat I shall now pass over to Nick
Halliwell from Grant thought and he will
present the audit Finance report
thanks Chris um so I was going to give a
sort of high level overview because I
know you've got a lot of things on the
agenda and the meeting art reports
obviously very large
um so this is our old findings report
for the 2020-21 financial year end
obviously this is quite out of date at
this stage given it's now two years past
that point as I think Chris gave some
training around the reasons and factors
behind those um delays in terms of the
audits
um there were also some specific factors
at the council that led to delay so um
specifically around the governance
issues that we identified in our
statutory recommendations as well as
additional work that was required on
Provisions relating to grievance matters
and disciplinary matters as well as the
birth for five
um in terms of our audit opinion on the
financial statements our expected
opinion is an unmodified and clean audit
opinion of the financial statements in
terms of the audit adjustments there
weren't a great deal of all the
adjustments there were there are some
areas where we acquired adjustments to
the accounts but versus other councils
it's a fairly clean audit report in
terms of actually the financial
statements being correct
um
in terms of the way we give our
assessment of the audit opinion what we
do is we give reasonable Assurance the
accounts are correct and in doing so
we've we set a materiality level that we
work to so the materiality level that
we've set for the council is 2.6 million
so our opinion is giving that assurance
that we're satisfied that the accounts
are fairly stated within that balance
and that reasonable Assurance on that
the way we set the materiality is um
sort of is typical across the public
sector audits that we do so we set it
based on Gross expenditure so we've said
it on two percent of the council's gross
expenditure
in terms of our audit opinion that we
will be issuing the audit opinion will
make reference to our value for money
opinion our value for money opinion is
still ongoing the reason it is unable to
be completed at this stage is that we
have seven outstanding objections
regarding the council's accounts and
until the work on those objections is
complete we are unable to certify our
value for money opinion but when in the
opinion that we will provide it will
make reference to the fact that there
were statutory recommendations and that
there was a significant weakness in our
opinion in relation to the council's
governance Arrangements in the 20 20 21
Financial year
um in terms of the time frames of the
value for money report we are looking to
take a paper to committee that will
cover the 2020-21 arrangements the 21-22
arrangements and the 2223 Arrangements
um so that's in September they were
looking to provide that report to the
committee so that I think that would be
quite a helpful report because clearly
the financial statements report that
we're providing you now is quite out of
date that should give you an up-to-date
view of our view of the council's
governance Arrangements ability to
deliver economy efficiency and
effectiveness
and also Financial sustainability
um I was going to pause there and just
to see if you've got any questions
around the the papers
before we go into questions I have uh
councilor Yates wishing to speak under
20.1 Council yeah something you've got
three minutes
thank you Jeff
um so I'm as Council scoby the chair has
said I'm just here to um add a bit of
flavor and we have context really
because it's your role to as governance
and audit committee to look into a lot
of these questions further um I just
wanted to speak on this point and just
say that some of the decisions we make
in this council do have um large
Financial impacts and if you look on
page 10 and Page 11 of the support
um it's mentioning net pension
liabilities of 102.7 million pounds and
the decision the full Council made to
bring East Ken housing in-house
um board also bought it in 10.6 million
pounds of pension liability and 6.9
million in pension assets so there's a
net impact of 3.6 million so I just
wanted to highlight
um the financial impacts of some of the
decisions get made here and
just yeah make that point thank you
do any members have any questions or any
points they wish to make
no um the only the only comment I had is
obviously
um when this uh your report and the
accounts were brought to the pre-meeting
governance and audit one of my concerns
was
why has this been delayed as a new
counselor onto the committee why has
this been delayed
um the in within your report I think
it's page 28 of our agenda which is I
think
page 16 of your report if any members
have any queries that sets out exactly
the time frames and some of the reasons
why so I found that quite useful I think
Others May
any other questions
okay with this agenda item is down
um that the audit findings report for 20
20 21 be considered yeah sure
I was just looking at the um on page 28
of our our agenda I think I've got the
right audit this thing called it
um
there was a point on where you say that
the committee was written to by the
external auditor with concerns regarding
a lack of governance and no action was
taken by this committee now obviously
different committee as Council skovies
just said there's only two members that
were on last year's let alone two or
three years ago
um are we happy internally about what
are the what are the risks that you know
why was no action taken at the time does
anyone know and are we confident in our
ability as a as a committee to be able
to take action should such a letter
arrive in the future
do any officers wish to respond to that
sure Chris
thank you
um
if I if I recall uh correctly that the
period of time that we were in it was uh
obviously a note the the comments that
Grant Thornton have made
um also in relation to if I just may add
before sort of answering the specific
question in relation to
um the value for money opinion that Nick
said has been delayed when
um Grant Thornton took the decision to
issue statue recommendations back in
October of 2021 that effectively
supersedes if you're looking at
hierarchy of action that an auditor can
take they can provide an adverse value
for money uh opinion we're effectively
they're saying the council doesn't have
Arrangements in place to provide value
for money
over and above that they can issue
statue recommendations the the
top level of is a public interest report
so in terms of looking at value for
money the
um apologies for the the credity of the
language and the terms the delay I'm
using the horse had already bolted so to
speak in terms of providing your value
for money because they'd already issued
statute recommendations so they've
already taken some action in relation to
that why the committee didn't address
those concerns it wasn't just from the
um external Auditors uh Christine Parker
as head of internal audits had written
to the three statutory officers at the
time and also to the chair of the
governance and audit committee
however I think unfortunately it was a
very complex matter that was being dealt
with by another Committee in terms of
they were primarily Staffing matters
that were being dealt with by the
council's general purpose committee and
its investigatory in disciplinary
subcommittee so to for the committee to
take any action at that time could
potentially prejudiced an
um a matter that was live and being
dealt by another committee another body
of the council that's my understanding
unless Christine or Samira you've got
anything else that you can add
okay thank you very much Chris Council
Towny
yeah I just want to Echo exactly what
Chris has just said uh we did raise
issues
you know as you have highlighted at the
moment
uh but because of what was going on we
could not in uh well we could
investigate a further investigation
during that period uh I certainly raised
issues which I've just spoken to Nick
about which were also told we can't go
forward with till those investigations
were completed and they were completed
quite some time later but it wasn't
anything that we were neglecting we were
very much aware
thank you Council the town anyone else
have any comments
no okay so um recommendation here is
that the audit findings report for 2020
2021 be considered as laid out in Annex
one I believe we have considered it can
I have a proposer and a seconder
councilor Donaldson proposing councilor
towning seconding everybody agreed
okay thank you very much
okay moving on to a gender item five
which is related to a gender item before
I'm gonna pass over to Chris Bundle
thank you Puck yourself in we're going
to go to the accounts Page by Page
no we won't
um okay so
um
this these are the accounts for 2021 as
I've said up previously they are two
years
um late however we did publish our draft
accounts on time Nick referred rightly
to some of the issues that related to
the delay in the audit just to
appreciate this was previous item a bit
of context around that there were right
there were governance issues at the
authority and it was appropriate for
Grant Thornton to delay it that is part
of the reason why we are where we are
with them now and why we've got the
delay
um that we have in terms of Futures I
will hand over to Matt he will give a
bit more of an overview in terms of that
the progress that we're making with next
year's accounts
you've received the Assurance from uh
Grant Thornton that as he said the
accounts are relatively clean that's
something we're very proud of in terms
of the quality of the work that's been
produced but they're also there's a
trade-off and I'm being honest here in
terms of accounts and how useful they
are accuracy is one part of it but if
timeliness is the other and there's a
compromise being between the two and
it's important that you have information
on a timely basis regardless of the
accuracy that's not to do with the
accounts production period process for
this year but we are fully committed to
making sure we're getting timely
accounts to you going forwards and we've
got a plan in place to do that but
before still any more of his thumb
though I'll pass over to Matt Sanam um
sorry Matt who is our financial services
manager and who leads on the production
of our financial statements
thanks Chris there's a bit of
duplication here as you can imagine
because the nature of the reports that
are being put in front of you but just
way of an intro the report covers the
financial statements or the accounts as
you will for 21 2021 Financial year the
context the draft accounts were
previously signed and published in line
with legislation on the 30th of July
2021 and were then due to be considered
by this Committee in December 2021 with
engagement sessions booked and
facilitated with members at the time
however due to various issues including
what Nick has said and Chris has covered
the issuing of the section 24 statutory
recommendations by Grant Thornton
ongoing discussions around birth or five
staff resources a case review of Grant
Thornton by the financial reporting
Council and finally the large proportion
of audit fieldwork that needed to be
undertaken remotely due to the various
issues in 2021-21-22 with covid and such
this is understandably had some impact
on the timeliness of the audit
Grant Fulton is required to report to
those charged with governance whether
the council's financial statements
present a true and Fair View of the
financial position it's expenditure in
income for the year and whether they
have been properly prepared Grant
Thornton's audit finders report was
previously covered as a separate report
to this committee setting out their
audit findings
the audience has concluded that subject
to completion of a few final tasks they
anticipate providing an unmodified
opinion of the accounts an unmodified
opinion is expressed when the auditor is
able to conclude that the financial
statements give a true and Fair View and
comply in all material respects with the
relevant financial reporting framework
from a value for money perspective the
Auditors are also required to reach
formal conclusion on whether the council
has put in place proper arrangements to
secure value for money the council
receive the number of objections as
covered off seven as Nick said
outstanding to the accounts on the
grounds of the council's arrangements to
secure value for money the Auditors are
examining the issues that have been
raised but in some instances these
issues span multiple years obviously
where they're linked to governance and
such
there are a number of objections to the
accounts that remain outstanding four
prior years and a separate report will
be brought to this Committee in
September covering 21 22 22 23 as well
as a backward Look in relation to 18 19
20 and 2021 hopefully closing off all
outstanding issues pertaining to value
for money
finally before final sign off of the
accounts by Grant Thornton and the
issuing of an unqualified or unmodified
opinion a letter of representation needs
to be signed off by the chief finance
officer or section 151 as Chris as well
as the chair of this committee
this will enable publication on the
council's websites which then fulfills
our legal requirements
this representation letter is provided
in connection with the audit of the
financial statements of financial
Council for the year ended 31st March 21
for the purpose of expression an opinion
as to whether the council's financial
statements give the true and fair uh
opinion as described previously
the version contained Annex 2 of this
report was for illustration purposes and
the final version which is largely
unchangeable presented to the chair for
Signature it's way of a further update
21 the accounts for 21 22 and 22 23 will
be starting an audit in relation to
those so Grant Thornton will be in
around October time provisionally we
will then look at doing 21 22 and 22 23
in Tandem and the expectation is the
2122 accounts will go for publication
next month so by which point we can draw
a line under and move forward with the
order
that's it from me
thank you any questions
um so I've got councilor Yates speaking
under 20.1 you have three minutes thank
you chair
um just to add a bit of uh flavor to the
situation in 2021 as uh I was
quite heavily involved in the covert
Grand situation so I just wanted to say
um that I think it's on page not 13.
um uh there was an extraordinary moment
where their Council was actually uh on
top of his doing his daily job was
responsible for administering 55 million
pounds of covert grants
um and just wanted to thank the council
and the civica
um
for doing that and it wasn't just one
Grant so I think there was about six or
seven each with their own specifications
of how it's being issued and to manage
and Minister that scheme on top of their
day jobs
um it was quite a lot of work and it
just I think in this on page 14 it
highlights that just one scheme alone
resulted in 5500 emails between officers
and I can well believe that as I was
involved with the businesses during that
period of time so
um yeah it's been a busy time thanks
do any members have any questions
um I have one
um on page 75 of our agenda 19 of the
report
um it talks about council tax recovery
that due to the pandemic there was no
enforcement activity so loss of income
when we have the next two sets of
accounts that we like to see council tax
income higher because we're able to pick
up enforcement or is that lost Revenue
completely this is Page 75 of the report
under
deputy chief executive in section 151
officer that's just that final bullet
point
so because that income was effectively
as a result of Court summonses because
they closed down the courts and there
were no cases all the cases were then
brought back together together in the
following year when the courts were open
so there's not going to be an increase
in income that income is effectively
lost as a result of the pandemic they
weren't there those debts are still be
pursued but they won't have been taken
forward in that year they would have
Consolidated that with the recovery
action that was taken in the following
year so if that makes sense there's no
additional income expected as a result
of that so if I can just add a little
bit to that
um so this line here where we're talking
about the loss of income as matters uh
actually said this is the income we get
from the court in terms of the if
someone is in arrears they have to pay a
court summons fee and we receive some of
that
um that was combined so we'd lost that
in terms of council tax itself
we we didn't undertake any recovery
action during the pandemic for obviously
the
um the appropriate reasons at the time
people were going through a period of
extreme stress and hardship
we have been able to recover a large
amount of those cases that were in
arrears and also offer some support
during that time it's difficult to throw
in mind back because actually it's been
superseded by the most recent crisis
which has been the energy crisis and
we've administered rebates of 150 pounds
to people over just the last year or so
and further support to people who are
also struggling with their council tax
however counts attacks collection is
still pretty healthy within the year we
tend to collect about 95 of the council
tax that's been billed for a year but
over a sort of four to five year period
collection is much closer to 99 of the
overall tax that we bill for which is
one of the most effective tax collection
rates if you compare it to other forms
of tax we've got a very high collection
rate council tax hazards um critics
criticisms for various reasons but it's
actually very effective and efficient
tax to collect
foreign
ERS want to ask any questions
nope so this agenda the uh this agenda
item recommendation is that the
committee approves the statement of
accounts for 2020 2021 and that the
committee notes the letter of
representation to Grant Thornton issued
by the director of corporate services in
section 151 officer can I please have a
proposal and a seconder councilor
britcher is proposing councilor bright
is seconding our members agreed
thank you very much
okay
we are
halfway through the agenda folks this is
good that is there's 238 Pages down
so agenda item six we have the corporate
risk management quarterly update and
over to you Chris
thank you chair
um so this is a standing item on the
agenda it will be presented to each
meeting of the committee that takes you
through our highest risks highest
highest profile rest high scoring risks
in across the whole Council so at the
front of
um
the first part of the report just takes
you through a bit of the context of how
we manage risks in the across the
organization if I can bring your
attention to
um section three
it's our go to the agenda pack so I can
give the the exact page
like
so on page 243
there's a table that sets out how we
evaluate our risks so you'll see along
the top the headings there risk can be
categorized into different uh different
packages different categories of risks
we will consider whether we're faced
with a reputational a strategic a
well-being or Service delivery of
Financial and compliance risk so we'll
assess the issue we'll we'll assess the
the risk that we're facing across those
different categories and then we
consider whether it falls into the
severe significant moderate or minor
category and we'll give it a score
depending on which one it scores on
highest across all of those categories
so we may consider that something is
unlikely to cause adverse publicity has
no significant impact on the delivery of
council's priorities isn't going to
impact on staff morale
there's no difficulty providing service
deliver three and there isn't a breach
of policy but if we don't do it we may
have a Financial Risk that's greater
than half a million pounds so although
although all the others are minor
because it's hit severe in one category
would give it a four for impact in terms
of how it affects us so that the impact
of a risk is how bad it would be if it
actually happened
on the next page we've got the
likelihood so this looks at the
possibility or the probability of
something happening and you've got again
four different categories whether it's
rare unlikely likely or very likely and
it'll be given a score depending on the
probability of somewhere between one and
four we then combine those two scores
together
in this Matrix just under Section 3.9
that gives this this overall score
that's set out on that color grid and
what we're looking at here in this
report are all the risks that are in
that red or the Amber section that are
scoring higher than eight
or nine there there are other risks that
they're set out in the annex
um that we're still managing and we're
considering but we're bringing the risk
to you that after consideration of all
the mitigating action that we're still
faced with these really significant
risks
so if I then move us on to page
245 under section four this is the the
nuts and bolts of the actual report the
table there at section 4.2 sets out the
risks sets out the description of what
the risk is what the score was at the
the of the rest the last time it came to
the committee in March you see it's
March 23 score and then how we're
scoring it now in July 23 finally a bit
of narrative to explain whether the risk
has changed the color coding again is
consistent with the table that we saw in
that Matrix of how we've scored them and
you'll see some of the risks have stayed
the same we've merged one risk because
it was uh inflation and cost of living
was becoming very similar in terms of
its nature and actions that we're taking
to address it to economic environment so
those two have been combined and we've
kept the highest score and then there's
been some reductions across some of the
other risks as well
if we go then on to section five this is
when we're actually providing the
committee within the report with some
detail of what those risks are I'll take
you through them now I'll give you a
high uh high level overview of what
those risks are and welcome any
questions at the end if you wish some
further detail on them so the first risk
here this is a Cyber attack its impact
is is for because it's pretty
catastrophic if it happens likelihood is
somewhere between
um at three and four but we've gone
prudently for a four score we're saying
it's four because we have seen instances
that this happen at other authorities in
the past and it is really debilitating
put my teeth back in what he said
debilitating I'm not going to try that
for a third time someone else say it for
me that one
um if if it does happen to an authority
we have got a you know we are exposed to
that risk and
um there was a briefing that was brought
to this Committee in private session of
the last meeting because what we don't
want to be telling you in public session
are all the actions that we're taking to
mitigate that risk because effective
that would be playing into the hands of
anyone that would want to undertake a
Cyber attack on the council
moving on to the next risk limited
resources this is one that's been on the
agenda for uh and on on our risk
registered for quite some time it's
talking about the financial landscape of
of local government per se and of the
authority it's one of the one risks as
it sets in out in the the uh report that
if it were to happen the council would
lose control of its own destiny and what
I mean by that when we were looking at
the training these authorities that um
have become bankrupt they've run out of
cash
in these instances central government
comes in they send in as I was referring
to Max caller some a commissioner some
of his his nature and help will come in
and effectively run the authority
controllers not just lost by officers
but by members as well
um
again in the body of the the report the
text sets out the
um the actions that we take to try and
address that in terms of the budget
setting process that we have the budget
monitoring uh reports that we produce
for members and for management to try
and uh address any variances to our
budget at the earliest possible
opportunity but some of these things are
just inherent to local government now
and to an extent are largely out of our
control without becoming too negative I
referred to in the training we are
seeing an increase in number of
authorities that are facing the
statutory section 114 notice which is a
notification that is given when
Authority runs out of cash we saw it in
the news only I think last week that
Kent have given warning that they are
only within two years maximum under
current projections of being in that
position and without any sort of uh
political or other biased I'm saying
Kent is a well-run Authority from a
financial management perspective we're
not talking about some of the failings
that were presented in the slide
otherwise this is just a an example of
the pressures that local government is
facing in terms of demand to place on
the services and the resources that are
available to address those pressures
um economic environments again this is a
higher scoring risk it's been merged
with the supply chain risk that was on
there previously because the the the
risks have merged in nature and in
effect
um this may have updated I'm not sure if
we've had the latest figures for July
actually 8.7 I think is still the
current figure which is stubbornly High
um
uh and it's having an impact across all
of our budgets in terms of the cost of
things just becoming more expensive but
fundamentally also on our residence and
what that means for us in terms of the
services that we have to provide to our
residents and the cost of those
homelessness is the following the risk
that follows on from this and this is
our big Financial pressure for us as an
authority it's the one that we have
um less scope to control it's a demand
lead pressure if people present them to
themselves to the council and they meet
the criteria of being statutory homeless
we have to provide that service to them
regardless of funding that we have
available to us so that is why it's
manifesting as a fundamentally a very
high Financial Risk but also Service
delivery and strategic risk in terms of
the capacity that we've got to do that
and also our objectives as the council
is to ensure that people have affordable
homes so that's why that is one of the
highest scoring risks
birth four five is still on the agenda
uh in terms of the risk scoring because
the the project is still to be completed
do have the director of environment
who's the risk owner here Mike cumber
who will be better placed than me to
answer any questions on that members so
wish to do so
then the environment act again Mike is
the lead for this and may be able to say
a little bit more about this as an
emerging sort of position in terms of
the environment act we're expecting the
extender producer responsibility to be
coming in sometime soon though there is
some there's been some
speculation in the local government
press that they that may be deferred and
if that is the case the risk may be
reduced in terms of its likelihood
change of EPC requirements this affects
our landlord function because we have a
responsibility to make sure our
properties have
um effective and efficient energy
ratings and those regulations are going
to become tougher and tougher over the
the future the there is a planned
timetable for I don't think we've got it
specified in here at the moment they
need to be e but I think with by the end
of the decade we're looking at C rating
and climate change uh we've got uh
councilor Rob Yates here with us who
declared the climate change emergency
back in 2019 I believe and we've
committed ourselves to the carbon
neutral by the end of the decade we're
in the process of setting the 24 25 year
budget next year we're halfway through
that time frame there's a lot of work to
be done still and we're Reliant very
much so rely on central government
providing the funding for us to
implement this because this is
incredibly expensive to do and is not
going to be achievable we within the
confines and the envelope the funding
that we've got just for ourselves
reducing risks I won't talk so apologies
I may have missed it did you skip over
homelessness and verse 4 and part of it
no homelessness um sorry I kind of
combined that with the financial
um resilience Financial Resources risk
homelessness is the the numbers are high
I can't remember the exact figure they
are not
1604 people in need of housing yeah yes
in terms of the number of homes that
we've gotten
um it's north of 200 uh to two yeah it's
there's it's a really really expensive
for us um but that's me looking at it
from a section 151 officer's perspective
in terms of budgery impact putting that
hard-nosed financial side there's
people's lives involved here in terms of
the impact that has on them their
children's schooling their ability to
access work and school it it really
really is a fundamental issue that's um
affecting not just Thana it's a it's a
um it's a nationwide issue in terms of
birth five four five sorry I did touch
on that very lightly just referring to
the fact that we've got Mike cumber the
director available can bring Mike in now
if you wish
all right thank you
um yes so the birth four five project is
on the risk register and that's
um mainly around the delay in the
project and around the Financial Risk
presented
um in July 2021 the budget was increased
um the work uh the program of the work
has been
so changing quite uh I think more than
20 months delayed and that was around
the need for an environmental impact
assessment
um which was needed to inform the
planning prior approval and the Marine
license
um in the end the work uh the majority
of the work took place over last summer
and it was substantially complete by
September last year
um leaving some uh main part of the work
that's left was electrical work which is
going on now and is due for completion
the first week in August
um the birth hasn't been handed over to
to the operator to Aggregates yet but it
will be very shortly as soon as that
electrical work is completed and then
bretts will have the ability to to use
the birth and to to do what they need to
do which would be to put a conveyor on
the birth so that they can import
aggregate via VIA the birth I think the
the outstanding issue is financial
and there is a live claim with the
contractor under the contract and that
claim is about
um that the contractor was awarded the
contract before we through the Marine
license constrained the uh project
period the the construction period and
the claim is around how the contractor
had to Resource that it's still live
it's not completed yet so I haven't got
figures to share but um that as well
we're hoping to be in a position where
that is finalized by around the end of
August time so we should be you know
should be in a position to report on
that then
thank you very much Mike I apologies
Chris do you want to continue with
reducing risks thank you firstly I need
to apologize to the committee on our
state to Matt I misspoke I've had a
nudge um frov not from Matt but um from
similar Matt's not our financial service
manager he's our head of Finance
following his promotion so I misspoke
um
does it say financial services manager
that is it how do Finance say go you
knew I didn't yeah amateur
um reducing risks
um this is a good night this is this is
the good news story as part of this
agenda item
um I remember back to a committee
meeting
um the two distant past uh councilor
Garner asked me when are we ever going
to see something on this agenda with the
risks reducing
um because it was a series of papers
coming forward with the risks at a very
high level
um within political stewardship
um that that has reduced significantly
given the fact that now we've got
overall control it was a high risk
previously because we had a change of
leadership of three times in about 18
months which obviously is difficult then
for the council to implement everything
it wants to do in its corporate plan
governance the risk has reduced as we've
made good progress with implementing the
recommendations of the independent
monitoring officer and Grant Thornton
statutory of recommendations what I want
to stress though is we're we're not
taking our Eye Off the Ball here we're
certainly not resting on our Laurels we
know the job's not complete in terms of
improving the governance Arrangements at
the authority and we will continue to
strive to do uh to to to get the desired
outcomes and uh
moving on to the next one uh coronavirus
yeah I'm sure the committee will share
my sentence when I say that we hope that
stays at a low likelihood for the
foreseeable future then finally the last
one is on Manson Road Depot again my
colleagues uh uh Mike Humber and Matt
Sanam may be better placed to speak on
this but the final paragraph just talks
about secondary EA visits where they
came and they were really pleased with
the progress that was made at Manta
Depot in improving the arrangements that
we've got there as it says recognition
in terms of the positive steps that
we've taken that's all that I've got in
terms of the committee's role here ask
the sort of notes and I think approve
the review of the the corporate risk
happy to take any questions and any
further comments that the committee may
wish to make
thank you Chris uh Council Yates you've
got three minutes under 20.1
thank you chair
um just wanted to make my my own like
higher level view on this corporate risk
register and just highlight
um
that in the economic environment has now
moved up to the the highest risk level
extreme risk and um I think we all as
gauss's feel that on the streets and
with the cost of living crisis
um and just highlighted it's not not
quite mentioned here that
um it's it's referred to with under
limited resources that the council
um is more reliant on locally raised uh
funds
um and it mentions the fact there is a
Star Chamber budget process underway I
just like to add that within that
process we're not just looking at how we
can make savings we're also making
asking officers how we can bring in
additional income
so there are
um
we are investigating all options for
that because it is something
um that we need to act react to thank
you
thank you Council Yates do any members
have any questions I have quite a few
but I will let others go first because I
can go on Council Ghana
thank you yeah and thank you for the
clear and concise explanation of the
this Factor yeah I do want to highlight
a couple of things well where we've got
a total risk it sort of alludes what you
said about
political stewardship and I've used that
a couple of times before
so where we've got just the top one
Cyber attack we're saying the score is
16. now it can't be any higher than 16
that is so we're a worse case scenario
we've got a potentially catastrophic
risk
and a likelihood
very high that it's happening so we
should be focusing
very carefully on getting that reduced
so I just want to highlight if we come
if we're looking at this say in three
months or in six months and it's still
16 then that's something we should be
really extremely concerned about so I'm
just seeking assurances that we are
taking action either ourselves to get
that reduced
um ASAP or at least with with work I
mean if it's similar in other councils
which I assume it is we're working with
those other councils across East Kent to
lobby as hard as possible government and
maybe County Council to give us the help
that we require and finances slightly to
get that to get that number down whereas
where we we you know we're opening
ourselves up to something catastrophic
thank you thank you Council Garner Chris
did you want to respond like
um
lots of
good points you've raised their accounts
Ghana
um try and take a few of those in turn
firstly
um
so the committee as I said was briefed
in private session
um back in the previous meeting in March
happy to if if the committee are minded
to do so to bring Dan Evans the head of
ICT across the East Kent partnership uh
back in to give an update on where we
are with that if the committee would
wish so
um in terms of working with East Kent
colleagues members may or may not be
aware so we used to have a shared
service for ICT across
um
three councils in East Kent ourselves
Dover and Canterbury the decision was
taken to disband that shared service and
disaggregate it that's a live project
that's happening at the moment staff
have all moved back in-house but there's
lots to be done particularly in terms of
disaggregating infrastructure that the
councils rely on
what we have kept together is the
security team because we're aware that
is a high priority for us and we did not
want to create turbulence in that area
until the the other parts of the service
had embedded into the new council's
in-house teams
Dan Evans is currently producing a paper
that will go to the east can chief
executive to set out how we continue to
appropriately resource and address the
security functions of ICT across the
partnership and that will be
considered in due course as to how best
that served them and provided I haven't
got the answer to that yet I've not seen
Dan's paper
but I think it as you say it is a really
high
scoring serious risk for us as a
sediment reduction it's
um it can authorities a Cyber
attack and it can leave us unable to
provide
services to our residents for a
prolonged period of time
without doubt the impact is most
definitely scoring four it's one of the
worst things that can happen to an
authority the likelihood is a bit more
subjective
I think set it somewhere between a three
and a four because you don't it's
impossible to predict if and when it
would happen by the nature of the risk
but prudently we've put it at the top to
ensure it has got the attention
what I can't promise and I wouldn't want
to promise is that risk is going to come
down immediately because it's such a
complex risk and no Sooners you've taken
action and got ahead of these sorts of
issues then the risk develops and you
know the the cyber security
issues and threats that we Face develop
further and we need to then respond to
that it's a very responsive and reactive
environment but
clearly as officers we're looking to
address that as soon as possible
and as I said happy to bring back Dan
Evans who looks after
it for the shared services if the
committee is minded to do so
Chris
um
on on that point I'll just I'll come
into before you question on Cyber I know
um that we've looked at Insurance
um we don't believe that the market is
conducive to our risk profile
I'm interested in what type of insurance
you're looking for is this the type of
insurance where assets are effectively
underwritten in some sort of business
Interruption insurance or will be
looking at some kind kind of insurance
where you will get Specialists to come
in if you have a breach who will advise
you and help you with your data
forensics and investigation what type of
insurance were we looking at there I
don't know the details of the policy
itself I I know it's bespoke cyber
security
um I'm Matt may be able to come in and
provide some more detail because he's
been closer to the issue than I have
what we've what we've been told in in
knowing certain terms is the paper
effectively is has so many conditions
that the policies of so many conditions
attach them that they're not worth the
paper that they're written on that their
insurers will find a way to set that
you're not complied with the conditions
of the policy that's the last time we
looked at it it's an expensive policy to
undertake and to take on the decision at
the time was that it wasn't best value
of the authority to take that given the
cost of it and the recourse that would
be provided through the policy but Matt
have you got anything else no
it's effectively as you've just said um
it's it's being looked at in the context
of you know best practice with other
partners and What insurances are
available and is anybody tapped into
something that we maybe haven't
considered at the moment there isn't
really anything available that's cost
effective in this market so we can it's
something that can be Revisited because
it's obviously always changing so I can
put that down as an action
okay and then I had just a question
again just sort of following on from
that around
leadership engagement in cyber risk and
whether any sort of
organization-wide testing has happened
so if it's one of our highest risks has
that been discussed at a senior level
and scenario plan to what the impacts
would be obviously that wouldn't be
appropriate to share with the committee
but just interested in whether those
discussions and testing has happened
in terms of discussion certainly this
everything that you see on the agenda
goes in front of our corporate
management team and some of it clearly
has
um more attention than others we spend
more time looking at the risk management
and the internal audit reports than we
do pouring over the accounts for example
so there is a lot of focus on risk
management at the corporate management
team it's it's brought there on a
quarterly basis the same as uh in line
with the the the pattern and frequency
that it comes to this Committee in terms
of testing it is something that we've
done in the past
um um again I wouldn't want to say the
details but a lot of it again is
education that we'll put out in terms of
two staff don't click on links that look
suspicious and and the like
um we've had issues where there's been
um other uh cyber-related frauds that
could be payroll frauds where people
have got into our accounts and into our
into our system and try to contact HR to
say that they wish to change Bank
details and they're like so these are
common things that that don't just
affect local authorities they're in they
happen across the country and we take
one of the best actions that we can take
is to constantly
reaffirm with staff through frequent
communication
action to take and fundamentally not to
take
thanks
apologies councilor bright
thank you I've got a question around
um the climate change
um question everything here is about
emissions and going green we've just
talked about one of the one of the the
risks that's going down is obviously
coronavirus and the fact that there's
obviously less of a thing what lessons
have we learned from the future impacts
of climate change so I'll give you an
example of water so water we currently
get 1100 millimeters of rainfall a year
in the UK but in the southeast of
England that's 600 uh yeah 600
millimeters because that's less than or
it's about the same as Lebanon and less
than Sydney so we're on an aquifer
28 of aquifers in this part of the
country have more water taken out of
them every year than is replaced so
we're going to have water shortages if
it carries on getting hotter we're going
to have water shortage water water
shortages probably sooner rather than
later so are there any lessons that can
be learned from the coronavirus actions
that we took that we can apply to that
to bring down the long-term risk and can
we do a study on the on the risks
incumbent in water supply
Chris thank you Chad
um I'll very briefly talk to this but
it's okay I'll bring in uh Mike cumber
again
um as the Director sorry Mike
um
I think that that there's clearly that
you know there's in uh government
inquiries in place in terms of the
lessons that can be learned nationally
in the terms of the covert response one
thing
um
without going to the details of covert
itself in terms of being prepared what
we are spending in increasing amount of
Senior Management time looking at is our
emergency planning responses to a number
of different scenarios
um and how you know that that is risk
management at its most acute you know if
we're presented with
um a particular issue how would the
council respond to that what is our how
does our business continuity plan
kicking in as we're saying if we were
left as a district as a region without
water for a period of time what do we
need to enact in our business continuity
processes in order to make sure that
we're still functioning as an authority
and also supporting our residents but um
Mike have you got anything that you can
add to that I'm sorry for them throwing
you in on that one no that's fine Chris
um I think yeah absolutely it's a really
valid concern but it's a national
concern to something you know for
example new legislation such as the
environment act this is about
lobbying water companies to make sure
that they are planning in advance so
that they you know are sorting out the
leak crisis where you know about a third
of the water that's uh that's produced
um is wasted before it reaches a tap
it's about making systems better making
sure that the catchment system works
more efficiently and that we can
distribute water more efficiently from
one uh Zone one place like you say you
know up in the Lakes where rainfall is
is huge and and you know compared with
here where it's where it's less so
um so I think this is very much a you
know a a bigger you know a bigger
national issue that that needs attention
um as Chris touched upon in terms of
emergency planning we have uh you know
an emergency plan we have business
continuity plans to deal with particular
emergencies we've obviously had our fair
share of water uh you know temporary
water outages where
um we provided assistance where we could
to Southern water although I have to say
that uh you know that that was quite a
difficult time and a difficult process
and there was you know a certainly some
ways in which that could be improved
um but we've we've always worked with
partner agencies in those sort of
instances and try to and try to help we
have mutual Aid arrangements with other
authorities as well so
uh yeah I think it's a very valid
concern but um but one that you know
needs to be a needs to be approached at
a at a at a national level
um yes councilor Barlow
Thank you regarding the um risk of cyber
Attack under five point section 5.1 of
tonight's gender it says that in the
event of ransomware the head of I.T led
a backup replacement project in
Partnership across the partnership
utilizing 350 000 pounds of funding from
the dluhc now I'd like to ask was that
it amount of money using the full extent
was that full money spent and can I ask
as well for a full breakdown of that
expenditure please
thank you Chris
I'm afraid I don't have the answer to
that to hand but I'm happy to provide
you a written response to them
thank you very much councilor manners
uh thank you chair I was uh on the
question of limited resources councilor
Yates alluded to the fact that officers
would be looking at ways of increasing
Revenue as well as looking at reducing
expenditure
so I was very pleased to hear that we
have a new head of property where
there's been something of a void in
recent years well in in since I've been
oh well
um I understand that there is a full
review happening of tdc's very extensive
property portfolio and it is a portfolio
that is
um by any objective measure remarkably
under let
underutilized and arguably
um there has been some neglect
in that area so I just want to make sure
given the scope for increased revenue
from the property portfolio
I'm actually aware of assets which are
under let to the the where where
premiums of several hundred thousand
pounds are take a a taking place in the
in the private Market on the on the
assignments for these leases
um given that that's money that should
be coming into TDC is the property team
properly supported to make sure that
they can in the vernacular sweat these
assets to ensure that we get the full
value for Council taxpayers in thanet
thank you
thank you and thank you Council for your
question
um
Matt may be able to tell me the exact
figures but it was I would say one of
the main topical themes that went
through this year's budget so when we
set this year's budget back in February
we put a lot of additional resource into
the property team on the premise that
that investment would lead to better
returns from our portfolio and it should
be self-funding across the short to
medium term
um
progress is being made
with that as you've rightly referred to
there are a number of properties where
rent reviews were overdue
that assets hadn't been fully
um
looked after in the way that we would
want them to so in addition to Staffing
we actually put some additional money
aside for repairs and maintenance of our
property stock as well to make sure that
they're up to us
a state where we can get the best yield
from them and or alternatively dispose
of them on the open market if that was
the best outcome but very much so the
team has been invested into over the
last
six months we're still going through a
process where some of those roles are
being recruited to there's been
extensive use of
interims in the property team both as
you refer to at very much the head of
property level where this is the first
permanent appointment of ahead of
property we've had for some time but in
the surveyor positions as well and we're
looking to get permanent additions and
have a full complement staff in that
team at the soonest possible opportunity
to allow us to as you say sweat those
assets to the um to the the maximum
opportunity
thank you Chris uh councilman of course
yes I think this ties in uh with the
legal team as well because I know for a
fact that there is a lot of leases
um six seven years out a date and when
Elise is out a date then the revenue is
stepped at the original price and needs
that review so there's an awful lot of
money being lost there
thank you councilor Nichols councilor
towning
I just wasn't too busy to know that I
have requested the chair to invite the
head of the State's Department to
accommodation set out her plan as to how
we agree forward with the review and
where the Investments and how she's
going to generate further income and
look at all the the dead wood that has
existed for quite some time
uh and that would be very helpful for us
to understand uh ongoing income and
having a proper review on a regular
basis from the property Department thank
you thank you Council towning and I will
take that away to speak with officers I
believe some of these matters will be
picked up when Christine comes on to her
agenda I can talk about some of the
audit covering but Chris did you want to
come in yeah just again
um chair I know you've set this up the
start it's important that we if we do
that and we invite the chair that we
stay focused on the processes that that
she at the Andrea plant the head of
properties following rather than getting
stuck into which properties that she
would be looking at because that would
be very very much a scrutiny area for
review in terms of the decisions that
we've been taking into which properties
we'll be investing in what we can do
obviously is look at what is the process
how often are you going to be doing rent
reviews all that kind of much higher
level stuff as opposed to actually
getting in you know looking at specific
properties per se that would be very
much a scrutiny topic
yeah and I'm I'll come to you in one
second constantly I was just going to
suggest that we may want to pick this up
under agenda item 10 because it may be
beneficial that our discussions follow
the internal audit plan because then we
will be you will have some sort of
response from the internal Auditors
about what Assurance they put on this
um I won't cover it now just because we
need to potentially move on and I've got
a couple of questions but did you want
to come back outstanding were you happy
with that
you know that's fine thank you very much
um so I just had a few quick questions
from me and then I'll double check if
anyone else
um just in terms of the report itself
um I don't know if this is I'm not
certain if I'm understanding this right
under each of the risks you have
obviously the description of the risk
the impact likelihood
whether it's current emerging future
then you have a risk score is that a
typo should that be the cumulative risk
or is it or am I missing something on
that good question um yeah but we can
make that clearer in future reports that
is setting up the category of risk where
it's high scoring so as I said we'll
take the highest score and risk so for
example limited resources we're saying
that's a risk score four in category
strategic and Financial
okay and then just stick in with each of
these risks then and we don't have to
cover this now I'd just be interested do
you when you look in each of the risks
do you have a Target score that you
track over time and secondly
um is there analysis is done about the
risk treatment as to whether it's
accepted transferred mitigated because I
think that might be interesting context
for the organization for the committee
because like when we were talking before
around cyber if the mitigations are
prohibitively expensive and
um very like for example insurance we
can't get the right product it may well
be that the organization has to accept
it but from a committee perspective I
think we would be quite interested
because we're accepting risks as a
council it may well be that
um you know and this is a good
opportunity where somebody like
councilor Yates is here that if it's a
political issue as to why we can't
mitigate things it may well be that the
cabinet should be lobbying the
government for investment I'm aware for
example example over in America with the
inflation reduction act huge amounts of
money has come from central government
in the U.S to rural local government and
state government for exactly cyber
security because they recognize that
there is a gap and that local
authorities will not be able to spend it
themselves and it may well be that
something similar needs to happen in the
UK but you won't get it if we don't
Lobby for it
um so in terms of the the processes that
all happens behind the scenes so um
happy to
um
happy a property chair for me probably
best if we if I have a discussion with
you on our next pre-meeting show you the
process that we go through and then we
can take a decision over the level of
details that you'd like to see in future
reports yeah and again we fully
understand that some of this stuff is
confidential and you know we we don't
want to become a committee that's
digging into the detail I know for
example we've got additional risks that
score below that we're starting to look
at and I think we may be stepping over
the line in terms of risks that we're
looking at but I just just wanted to ask
those questions and the final one
um before I sort of pass over to any
other members who may have questions was
just on the risk around economic
environment
there is a point towards the end talking
about
um Supply at risk and and some of the
mitigation that the procurement team do
um could I request that for the next
meeting we just have a little bit more
information as to what's been done
because there's a line there it says we
scrutinize the rationale for supplier
adoption and undertake a company credit
check via credit safe
um now those are good mitigations I
would imagine that there is more and I
certainly know from other public sector
organizations the impact of supplier
liquidation or a supplier having a cyber
risk for example and then that being
transferred up has a sort of double
whammy effect I'd be interested just to
see if there's any more information
around that if it is commercially
sensitive or confidential that's fine
but if we could have a little bit more
information for the next meeting that
would be helpful not a problem at all um
if I'm happy to give a very brief verbal
update if you if you wish so obviously
again the rest would depend on the the
aspect of the risk that you're
addressing so from a financial
perspective there are terms and
conditions and the majority of cases
will require the services delivered
prior to payment being made so that
mitigates the fact of the company goes
into Administration and becomes
insolvent that we've not lost money
those Services have already been
provided the risk obviously we have is
service disruption
um one of the one of the benefits of
having it in-house service compared
compared to say a neighboring
authorities who have outsourced a number
of their front line services such as
waste collection is that is mitigated to
a degree in terms of service disruption
but the the checks are undertaken not
just on
um at the point of uh supplier adoption
we also do reviews as well in terms of
supplier performance at certain points
in the contract
um is there anything else you wish to
add at the moment in terms of that's an
annual role in processing relations and
sort of large contracts to making sure
that their accounts are still presented
as they were when they originally had
the contract let to them so but again
beyond that happy to add some go away
have a look add some further detail to
the report and open up further scrutiny
from the committee yeah I'd certainly be
interested and again not to share the
information whether there is any
analysis of single Source suppliers or
whether there's any analysis of
suppliers whose turnover from the
council is a large proportion so I'd be
interested if you do anything like that
again not interested in actual details
or any supplies because it's
commercially sensitive but it's just
interesting in how we're mapping those
supply chain risks yeah we'll set that
all out I mean just having a little side
conversation with Matt I know
um that if that goes into the evaluation
of the score we have a threshold that
they have to meet if they don't meet
that I would have to sign it off in
terms of Works we're willing to accept
that risk and we wouldn't be willing to
accept certain large value contracts in
particular where it is a significant
proportion of that supplies income if we
know that you know this is out
proportion for them and they are
becoming very reliant on our business
that they wouldn't um in fact he
wouldn't pass the bar
okay
okay so members this is down for us to
approve the review of corporate risks
and for us to discuss Annex risks
does anybody before we go to
um getting a proposal saying does
anybody have any more questions
no can I report oh yeah counselor
Richard
yes
um I'd remind one in the annex bit
um as I mentioned burial space
I've been bought sort of time scale are
we talking
on that one because that seems to be
running out of
space for that is that a several years
thing or is that quite imminent
Chris uh chair for May pass over to uh
Penny button our head of neighborhoods
who looks after bereavement services
sorry I was just asking how I can answer
that question and it it very much
depends on demand
um in terms of whether
um burials become more popular than
cremation
um it we are working on a plan to look
at extending the current sites
um long term we will have to extend
further
um out of the current
um confines of the the Margate cemetery
and
we're not about to run out imminently as
in the next three months or anything
like that but uh we are
rearranging the way that we um manage
the space at the moment to make extra
space because it is something that
should have been looked at a long time
ago
thank you very much Penny yeah
um any other oh yeah counselor yep just
Donna come back on going back right to
the beginning of what I was saying but
it was mentioned about getting the head
of i i t in to give us another
update can we arrange to do that please
yeah I'll speak to officers about when
it would be appropriate the key thing I
want to make sure we do because I'm
aware that we're going to have more
accounts coming to this committee and
bearing in mind I think um everyone will
probably if we had a 450 page agenda
plus a half hour q a with an I.T manager
I think we generally would be here till
midnight so I would will certainly get
him in or them in but I think we just
need to make sure coordinating agendas
so we don't overload people that'll be
the only reservation I've got
no absolutely yeah
okay members can I have a proposer and a
secondary to approve the review of
corporate rests and discuss and the fact
that we've discussed Annex risk can I
have a proposal please
councilor britcher seconder
councilor Donaldson
thank you very much members
uh so we're going to move on to agenda
item seven contract standing
oh apology test do we agree
thank you very much I've jumped ahead
um agenda item seven contract standing
order waivers um I think I'm passing
over to you Chris and then you're
passing on to somebody else so
you'll be pleased to hear this is the
last item you'll hear from me for a
little while until the last one so you
roll up a break from me
um I do I'm not going to ask her to um
to go through the report but I do we do
have with a slight Gemma Paul who's our
procurement manager who needs to pass my
thanks on appreciation who uh for
authoring this report and also taking a
lead on the council's procurement
activity
um in terms of the report itself so
um going back to sort of Basics we have
real procurement is all about buying
stuff buying things and buying services
and the processes that we follow in
order to make sure we're doing that in
the best possible organized way
they that the way that we do that is set
out in the council's contract standing
orders which is part of our constitution
it's effective the rules for the council
to for buying things
um the take the the reports
um sets out there's various different
um uh processes that need to be followed
depending on the nature of the contract
and its value so page 265 of your agenda
pack table one sets out the different
processes that need to be followed when
we're procuring good supplies and
service contracts
um and you can see that below ten
thousand pounds at least one quote in
advance is required in order for the
manager to demonstrate that they've got
value for money
between
um 10 and just under a hundred thousand
at least three written quotes in advance
are required using our council's
invitation to quote process
then between 100 and 177
897 pound and 99 Pence
we have to get three written Tenders in
advance which is a step up in terms of
detailed requirements compared to the
invitation to quote
above that there are legislative
requirements that are set up in the
public contract regs 2015 well we have
to go out via fully compliant tender
process
um and we can't deviate from that
because that's a legal requirement to do
so
unless there is a framework in place and
a framework is a a scheme where you can
call contracts off it that's been
provided by a separate body and it's
recognized as a compliant way to procure
table two very similar set of
um of rules that set out but in this
instance we're dealing with work so
that's construction and and building
stuff effectively and you'll see right
at the end the limit is much higher
where those public contract ranks come
in that's just shy of 4.5 million pounds
um so they're moving through
um the reports a little bit
it sets out
um under section four
instances where we may not follow those
rules and where we do that's called
waving contract standing orders and they
can be very valid uh reasons for doing
that it sets out at section 4.2 when
it's deemed in the best interest of the
public or the service
see the bullet points that set you up
there
it could be
um
it could be that there's a single Source
supplier or it could be that we weren't
able to get hold of
um three quotes that the Market's not
responded to it and therefore waivers
will be put forward in front of the
procurement manager to consider they'll
challenge the the officers to make sure
that they can evidence that there wasn't
a compliant procurement rule process
that they could have gone through and
then ultimately it's presented to me to
sign up as section 151.
section 6 of the report sets out the
number of waivers that have been
approved across different departments
this is a backwards look because
obviously we're looking at 2223 under
the previous structure
deputy chief executive looks quite high
but that does include housing so that's
not just all back office services and
then operational services are the
majority of our front line services so
you can see during that period there
were
45 waivers approved the vast majority of
them were for relatively low value
contracts so they were below a hundred
thousand pounds 40 of them there was one
waiver that was rejected during that
period of time that's because they'd
already undertaken the activity it was
they're acting for asking for
retrospective approval and we both said
you've already done it we're not going
to prove it
um
uh so
uh then moving on to section seven we've
got similar information setting out the
uh position to date in terms of the
number of waivers that have been
approved and you can see again the
majority of them two-thirds of them are
for contracts that are below a hundred
thousand pounds
uh going forwards we are looking at the
moment at um we have we're on the middle
of a review of our procurement processes
we're very mindful that we've got a lot
of procurement activity we've got a
hundred million pounds to spend across
our Capital program in the next four
years and we need to make sure our
procurement
processes are
flexible enough allow us to do that at
PACE in order to deliver those schemes
without jeopardizing the the overarching
aims of our procurement rules that is to
demonstrate that we're getting value for
money and that we're not exposing the
the council's sort of
um over charging from the the third or
secondary parties that we're Contracting
with so that's a live process at the
moment and we're hoping
um to be concluding that soon because
it's part of the Constitution that will
go through the Constitutional review
working party uh so members will have
oversight of that as and well it is
approved
so there are accompanying this report a
number of annexes so Annex or appendix
one sets out the
sections of from the contracts standing
orders saying when waivers may be
applied appendix 2 is a
um a template application form for
waivers and then you've got some more
background information that detail when
we have applied waivers so this is an
important part of the committee's
business because we're bringing this to
be transparent with members to
demonstrate to you when we haven't gone
out to Market through a fully
um competitive process because that is
our default position in order to
demonstrate and Achieve value for money
in our procurement activity so just
returning to the top the committee is
asked to note this report and I'm happy
to take any questions or comments from
the committee
thank you Chris
um and I'll just
um remind members that obviously under
appendix four and five there are a
number of decisions all of those
decisions will have been appropriately
been dealt with at the time members are
more than welcome to ask questions and
I'm sure Chris and the team will answer
those if you're unhappy with any of
those decisions there are other
committees and other ways to raise those
concerns so I just wanted to remind
people of that does anybody wish to
speak on this agenda item councilor
britcher
yes I just want to ask
um especially obviously this was all you
know the co-vid years
um was is 45 a higher than normal number
of waivers over the course for a year or
is that fairly normal
sorry uh thank you councilor so if you
look at I'm just trying to get the annex
number right so it's on page
281 of
um the agenda pack that Annex three got
some details there of the year so 45 is
the financial year 22 23 so we're
probably just post pandemic there uh in
terms of the time frame starting in
March 22. I appreciate there were still
restrictions at the beginning of 2022
but I think by the time we got to April
the majority of those had passed
um you can see they compared so the
orange section is
um for that year and the years prior to
that 21 22 and 2021 they were higher
during the pandemic however that is
caveat that we did relax our rules
during the pandemic so that requirement
to only get one quote was increased from
10 to 25 during that period because we
knew we needed to act quickly with
although we wanted to be able to still
demonstrate value money we're working at
such Pace that we needed to flex those
rules and again that's what we're
reviewing at the moment because of the
capital program it's it is a time
sensitive issue for the delivery that in
terms of whether it's high or not
um it's difficult to make comparators
between year and different authorities
because as I said earlier we provide an
in-house Waste Service so we wouldn't be
going out to contract for for those
things I think it's more important when
you're looking rather than the numbers
per se for the rationale for the the
waiver that's been given that's no I
don't think there's a particular number
that is good oh that we would be
targeting but in general they should be
in it by exception unless there's a good
good reason to do so
thank you any other members wish to
speak
counselor town
where's this the emergency powers of of
her pre-corbid fall into the waiver side
because it takes me back to
2019 when we were acquiring a couple of
um
sorry Mike I don't need to upset you
we were acquiring a couple of politunes
and then suddenly
uh ex-con councilor bayford was asked to
sign off
very large sum of money to acquire these
pontoons
where does this fall into this precorbit
area
uh chair from A3
um so and again I'll try not to accept
my Humber as well because this was uh I
think it's it was um
um it was a it was an issue of of debate
between officers and I don't think there
was a right answer to this and we've got
external legal opinion on it
um so if you look at the uh try and get
to the right section of the report
apologies find the right page
sorry so page
265 we've got our good supplies and
services and as I said anything above
177 000 has to go out to a fully
compliant tender but if it's a Works
contract the limit's much higher now
we've got legal opinion that said it it
uh it could be considered a Works
contract and that's why it was able to
be waived and that's why we didn't have
to go through a fully compliant process
nonetheless it was a key decision
because we're talking about spending
serious money so it's not something I
could just sign off and that's why it
required a cabinet decision
as well like sorry
um yes so just to just to follow on from
that
um there was a process that that we went
through with the with the procurement of
the pontoons and there was a proposal
made for a contract
um under a single Source supplier but in
fact uh in December
again the years right 2020 I think uh
the decision was made at cabinet to go
out competitively for a Works contract
and in fact that's what happened and the
contractor bam Nuttall who owned the
pontoons
um uh priced that job and were
successful through a competitive tender
exercise so in the end actually it was
it was a competitive exercise that uh
that that the contract was awarded upon
my apologies Mike yes I've missed that
crucial piece of information
it was a long process yeah
happy that counselor Tony yeah yeah
councilman space nope you're okay
okay members we are asked to note the
report everybody happy that we know this
yep okay uh moving on to agenda item
eight uh Samira uh can you please
introduce your report please
my report is complete and financial I've
got no figures here at all so you can
relax and Chris can take a break as well
right mine is the annual governance
statement which is a statutory
requirement as Christian alluded earlier
on
and it explains the process and
procedure that are in place to enable
the council to carry out its functions
effectively
the AGS which is known the annual
government statements is attached as an
appendix one to this report which
appears on your page 299 of the agenda
the AGS is a key corporate document for
which the leader and the chief
executives are responsible less
signatory they also require to ensure
that it reflects our governance
framework in full
I like to highlight I'm not going to go
through the whole report because it's
quite detailed and I appreciate you've
had enough of all the figures and
everything but I just want to highlight
a couple of things the first is the IMR
report which is public which was
published into 2022 which can be found
on page 308 of the statement
the statement also addresses the both
internal and external Audits and
outlines the achievements in there the
works of the Rose committees are also
enlisted in there including the GPC
which agreed and endorse some of the key
policies which were highlighted by the
IML report which included the absence
The Bullying the disciplinary the
grievance and Performance Management
which were crucial to the IMO
recommendation and then they they report
the student also addresses the
ombudsman's cases which has been dealt
by the Ombudsman and you'll be pleased
to note that we had there were 27
complaints that were sent that received
so you know sent received by by the
Ombudsman of which only one was upheld
and the other 12 were not upheld by the
Ombudsman previous years we had in the
region of 30 32 complaints
um so it's it's gone done and slightly
which is good news
members of the DNA committee was to
agree the AGS report a statement for
20223 once he's agreed to be shared with
external Auditors and published
thereafter
happy to take any questions
do any members have any questions or
comments on this report
okay thank you very much we are asked as
Samira said to agree this can I please
have a proposer and a seconder
councilor towning to propose a second to
please
Council Deborah
do members agree
thank you very much
okay moving on to agenda number nine
which we want the ex the internal audit
who've waited patiently all evening so
far as we've gone through the previous
eight agenda items so this is agenda
item nine quarterly internal audit
report and I'm passing over to Simon
Webb welcome to the meeting
thank you chair good evening members
my name is Simon Webb I am the deputy
head of the East Kent Audi partnership
um I work for Christine and we provide
your internal audit service
um as part of that we will provide you
with Assurance on the areas of Risk
Management corporate governance and
internal control across all areas of the
council's operations
this is a standing agenda writer before
this committee and you'll become used to
the format of this report as the year
unfolds
um basically it provides an update on
the work completed on your behalf by the
UK and audit partnership since the last
meeting of this committee together with
performance of the skin audit
partnership up to the 31st of May
if I could draw your attention to the
table on page 315
that provides details of the seven
internal audits completed during this
period
at the end of each audit we conclude an
opinion an assurance level and you can
see from the table that that can be
anything from substantial Assurance down
through reasonable limited to no
assurance
in terms of what that actually means if
I could draw your attention to page
that contains the definitions for each
of those Assurance levels now they are
the Sip for definitions of the Assurance
levels which will be used by internal
departments across the country
as part of each audit we also make where
appropriate recommendations for
improvement and we classify those
recommendations in terms of their
priority now they could be critical high
medium or low priority and again on page
332 within those definitions we Define
what we mean by critical recommendations
Etc
so looking at the table on page 315
across those seven organs that we've
completed we do in fact have all four
Assurance levels
we were pleased to conclude substantial
Assurance in the areas of Environmental
Protection and also sundry debtors four
marks to pennies environmental health
Team
substantial Assurance with no
recommendations that really is a very
high bar to achieve
some areas of the council's businesses
we break down into constituent parts we
do quite a few environmental health
audits this one was contaminated Land
Air water quality
Sandra debtors that's managed on your
behalf by civica
third audit um in that area was refuse
collection again this is a very
important part of the council's
operations a very visible
activity in terms of the public
and we do separate audits of things like
Street cleansing and waste vehicle Fleet
Management pleased to report reasonable
Assurance in the area of refuse
collection
also pleased to report reasonable
Assurance in the area of vat probably a
slightly dry topic but yeah that was a
very good solid reasonable Assurance in
that area
absence management
the findings weren't as good
particularly as employees are the most
important and largest asset within any
organization certainly within a local
Authority
now we sometimes split Assurance levels
if it's appropriate to do so and we've
done that on this occasion so we've
split the Assurance between management
of annual leave sickness and flexi leave
annual leave is fairly well controlled
through the East Kent people system and
we were able to conclude reasonable
Assurance in that area
sick leave whilst The Authority has
fairly good policies and procedures and
I think in the training Chris Blundell
talked about having good procedures
however if they're not followed by
managers then
whilst not worthless they're
um well he does call into a question how
valid they are and certainly with regard
to sickness there was a lack of
following of procedures consistently
across different departments within the
council
flexi leave
um
problems there really with consistency
and also not having a defined system for
controlling flexi leave within the
council
licensing we've spread this it was
largely reasonable Assurance but there
was an aspect of it which we felt was no
assurance and that was that there should
be a cost neutral exercise Undertake and
the fees and charges based upon that
cost neutral exercise so that the
authority neither makes money out of it
nor loses money over roughly a
three-year period but at the time of the
audit there was no evidence that was
being done
car parking
um again very important aspect of the
council's
operations and indeed there is reference
within the corporate plan to car parking
enforcement
unfortunately we were only able to
conclude no Assurance in that area we do
have penny with us this evening and I'm
sure that she'd be happy to help if you
have questions on that area
page 316 onwards we provide the detail
of why we've concluded the Assurance
levels that we have in each of those
areas so for each area we will provide
the scope of the audit and then a
summary of the findings and hopefully
the bullet points take you in a logical
sequence through why we have concluded
that Assurance opinion
it's somewhat ironic I suppose that all
internal work is very fact-based and
evidence-based but it does result in an
opinion the Assurance level which
obviously has with all opinions
is subjective to a certain extent
so um
on the pages 316 onwards we break down
the findings for each of those seven
areas
now a very important part of internal
audit work is follow-up once we've
concluded in an audit as we have done
with these seven areas we don't just
take Management's word for it that
they're going to implement the
recommendations that they've agreed with
us
approximately three months later we will
go back and do a follow-up all day
so if I can draw your attention to the
table on page 324 that details the five
follow-ups that we concluded during this
period
um in the area of thane Community Lotto
the original Assurance level was limited
and I'm afraid to say that the Assurance
level after follow-up was still limited
with a significant number of
recommendations still outstanding after
follow-up
so you'll see from that table that for
each of the five areas we show the
original Assurance level the revised
Assurance level we tell you how many
recommendations we made initially and
then how many have followed sorry how
many are outstanding after follow-up
um any critical or high priority
recommendations that are still
outstanding after follow-up they are
detailed within the body of this report
they are on page 333 onwards and that
table details as I say critical and high
recommendation I priority
recommendations outstanding after
follow-up
also still limited or no Assurance after
follow-up was museums again still quite
a lot of recommendations outstanding at
that time
and then the final of the five dog
warden fly tipping and littering again
an important and very visible service in
terms of public perception reasonable
Assurance in most of those areas apart
from litter enforcement which is a
corporate priority but the council isn't
currently undertaking any so we could
only conclude no Assurance in that area
I think the council is currently in the
process of putting together a new
corporate plan for 2024 onwards so
obviously it will need to determine
whether that remains a corporate
priority
for each of those areas we have details
of why we concluded they were still
limited or no assurance and there are
also management written responses for
those areas
um on page 327
um we detail current work in progress so
they're audits that we are currently
undertaking that will come to Future
meetings of this committee one that I
would particularly draw your attention
to um and it's one of the most important
pieces of work we will do this year is
cyber security it's obviously been
discussed already
um as part of the risk management item
on the agenda this evening and it's
quite right and proper to proper that
there is a direct Synergy between the
risks faced by the council and the work
of internal audit power so that is
currently a work in progress I don't
think I can promise that you'll see the
results in September I think it will
probably be the November December cycle
of this committee that we will bring it
to
possibly chair you might think that once
that report comes to this committee that
might be an appropriate time to invite
Dan Evans back
um to provide an update depending on the
findings
um
so yeah
um external funding protocol Garden
waste all of those audits are currently
in progress and they will come to
September and December meetings
in terms of the appendices to the report
one of the most important ones is
appendix one which starts on page 329
now that shows the agreed 2324 audit
plan for the council that was agreed by
this committee back in March
we do review all areas of the council's
activities typically over a four to five
year cycle but some areas get related a
lot more frequently than that because
they're high risk high profile corporate
priorities
Etc
so you'll see the plan broken down
between Financial audits housing audits
Etc the original number of planned days
that were approved back in March the
total size of the plan is 300
348 days the revised budget if it's
changed this early in the year we don't
expect to see too much change but the
plan will change with as risks change
through the course of the year
we then show you the total amount of
time that we spend against each audit
we've taken it up to the 31st of May
and then the status and insurance level
so for example some of those audits are
currently work in progress
um others we've indicated what quarter
they will be undertaken in and there's a
few um starting to be finalized
um as at 31st of May we had completed 16
17 of the agreed number of days I can
update the 30th of June that was up to
23 so very much on target for a very
healthy plan completion uh by 31st of uh
March next year
um page
331 that shows the plan for Eastgate
services in civica that used to be a
much bigger plan incorporating HR ICT
Etc as those Services have come back
in-house they've been incorporated into
the main funnier plan there also used to
be a separate Eastern housing plan which
we audited again once that came back
in-house those days were incorporated
into the main Planet plan EK Services
now is predominantly benefits council
tax and ndr uh Sunday debtors and
customer services
um
appendix
to the definitions I've already covered
that's on page 332.
um as is also the case with the
recommendations outstanding after
follow-up
um
the final appendix to talk to is a
balanced scorecard of key performance
indicators for the esken audit
partnership itself that is on page 338
we broke we break it down into four
different perspectives and internal
processes Financial customer perspective
and also learning and Innovation
um a couple of the key performance
indicators I've already mentioned which
are plan completion which this is at
30th of June so it was 23 for thanet
cost per audit day we calculate that
once a year you will see in the next
agenda item which is the annual audit
plan uh the cost for 2223 and the budget
of 400 day sorry the budget of 403
pounds for 23.24
um
obviously
customer feedback is important we do
issue a questionnaire at the end of each
audit to ask customers what they think
we don't get as many back as we would
like but we do get high levels of
satisfaction particularly considering
that the order team knows what the
Assurance level is before they complete
the questionnaire
um obviously it's also very important
that um not only are we reasonably cost
effective
um uh deliver the audit plan and Achieve
customer satisfaction it's also
important that we're doing it with staff
who are qualified
um and we do have a very good
qualification base Within These kennel
partnership Christine and I as an
example are chartered internal Auditors
with the Institute of internal audit and
we also do make sure that staff do
undertake relevant Technical Training
and meet their formal CPD requirements
post qualification
hopefully that provides you with a good
summary of the quickly update report for
this period happy to take any questions
that members may have chair thank you
thank you Simon that was a very
comprehensive overview
um just before I open up to questions
there's a couple of points I just wanted
to make
um councilor Garner bearing in mind
there's going to be internal and cyber
security that's going to come back I
think you said time in November
that may be the time that we ask the
relevant officer to come to the meeting
so there will be we will have some
detail of assurances of the processes
and then we can talk more around the
risk side as well so there might be a
bit of a double whammy there if you're
happy with that
uh members sort of agree that that might
be a good approach we'll obviously have
to check Diaries and stuff but we'll
have that as a draft plan
um second thing to say and I think um
this has happened in the past where
recommendations or audits have taken
place and have come back to the
committee a couple of times and not been
implemented
um I think we have a role members in
supporting internal audit here if we are
seeing matters coming back with limited
or no assurance and action not happening
I do think we have a responsibility to
flag that up to Cabinet our
recommendations go direct to Cabinet we
have Council Yates here as well
um I'm I'm not
um enough over the detail for this
committee meeting to know whether any of
the matters that Simon sort of outlined
where they're still like with the lotto
issues and be raised but I will
certainly keeping an eye on behalf of
the committee to make sure that any
recommendations that you make that are
being repeated time and time that we may
well picked up and refer that to Cabinet
um
I've got one question I hope you were
quick one Simon on um your audit of
Licensing you reference and you said it
in your um section when you introduced
it around the cost neutral exercise for
fees
now I was just interested because
um
is that just a licensing thing because
obviously as um as discussions happen
around the risk register councilor Yates
himself said the council was very
reliant on fees and charges for our
income and there is obviously High
inflation at the moment I think the last
Figures were 7.9
um is that across the board on other
fees or is that literally just for
licensing that it has to be done on a
cost-neutral basis and not related to
blank increases
thank you chair
um from memory that also applies to land
charges and building control
um Matt's nodding I don't know if
there's any other areas apart from those
three
there are restrictions in relation to
parking we can't just have a blanket
approach to fee increases on parking it
has to be driven by effectively a
strategy to reduce the number of cars
and where they are and manage traffic
rather than just a blanket increase so
there are other restrictions
these tend to be done as a matter of
course these reviews
we don't refund obviously if you're if
you set the fees for example licensing
and you set it in year one on a
break-even basis there's an expectation
over that three years that you would
continue to manage it and every year
drops out a new one drops in and you do
another review so I don't think
necessarily licensing is an example is a
massive issue and I remember my team did
look at it not you know has looked at it
previously with regards to this
Breakeven position but the high
inflation rates and various other
different bits and pieces do have an
impact and it's a changeable environment
so
thank you councilor manners
uh thank you Simon that was actually a
really good insight into how the how the
council is performing um
uh the question I have is regarding
parking
um the the uh the scope of your audit
was that presumably is just as the
existing status quo with existing
um
Street infrastructure and existing
parking spaces did it take into it did
it look at
um I mean the the reason I'm asking the
question is the chaos that we have
um in in my area
um in botany bay and Palm Bay with day
trip visitors who are parking on crowded
being funneled into crowded residential
streets where no revenue is being
generated whatsoever from their their
visit to our Coastline
um did was that taken into consideration
with your audit or was it exit based
solely on the existing infrastructure
because I think most residents would be
concerned to know what what is being
done is there a plan to actually address
the the issue of day Trippers parking
thanks
thank you
um it was based on the existing
infrastructure
um I don't know if um Benny would like
to speak about the policy in those
particular areas
I'm happy to just do a summary of the
situation we found ourselves into how we
got to know Assurance which is what I
prepared for this evening if you're
happy for me to do that chair
um obviously we as a team are extremely
disappointed to receive no Assurance
um in our parking audit but it's
understandable given the situation that
our team has been in in the last year or
last two years to be perfectly honest
we've had no team managers in place um
due to absence and an inability to
backfill despite consistent efforts
um maternity cover in parking is not
something that happens very often and is
not something that we manage to do
um
coupled with that we have
um a completely new team so we were
dealing with a new team of officers in
our administrative side of things who
didn't have that background and
knowledge for some of the questions that
we were asked in our audit
um
one of the things that did come out from
the audit is how extremely good our
written procedures were for our everyday
work and
that is reflected in the comments that
were made unfortunately it's not the
case for the management side of the
business and that's where things have
slipped through the cracks so in some
areas we were undertaking checks and
balances but we weren't able to
demonstrate to the auditor
um with written evidence of how we we've
done those things um because we didn't
have that in place
say what the team have done now is we
actually have a full management team in
place they've worked through some of the
issues highlighted in the report we are
establishing a management procedure
so that if we find ourselves in a
situation where we have long-term
absences again we're able to pick that
work up without anything falling
um
whilst this isn't an order outcome that
any of us ever want we are actually
quite grateful for the recommendations
because we've been able to take them and
then actively look at ways of continuing
to prove the service that we're
providing so in terms of
um
the situation we find ourselves in now
is very different to the one that we had
in the audit a few months ago and
hopefully will be very different to the
one when you come back to see us in the
autumn
Council manager do you have any
follow-up
um I think I'd just like to say that I
think um
parking needs to be we do need a
thorough review of parking in thanet
coming back to the uh the risk factors
that we we spoke about earlier with um
Revenue being a major source of you know
a focus rather than just expenses I
think parking Revenue should be a
greater Focus for us for um you know
when we look at the visitor economy that
was that was and hopefully that will be
looked at at some point with the parking
review thank you thank you very much do
any other members have any questions
yes councilman I know it's um it says at
the moment there's five uh CEOs I guess
they're Enforcement Officers is that the
current is it currently five or is it he
said it should be up to 11 but how are
we going to get to 11.
um so we're currently on
five I believe and getting to 11 is
extremely difficult we've had adverts
out all of this year and all of last
year and we yeah we're just difficult
it's difficult to recoup recruit people
on that that area we have some um
how to put this some things in some
proposals in in the pipeline of how we
might be able to encourage people to
come in but I have to get them through
the finance system first
can I come back on yeah
okay so um we can't just charge
um what we like for parking
unfortunately it has to sit within the
legislation and I'm looking at a map for
this because he knows way more than I do
about how we uh calculate our fees and
charges for that and we can't use it as
a revenue stream and I think I need to
make that very clear tonight we cannot
use parking as a revenue stream and we
have got the strategy that's going out
um for tender at the moment
um and we are hoping to bring that back
to Cabinet in January and that will be a
review of where our car parks are where
our parking is and so
and hopefully that will provide us with
the strategy we need to tackle some of
the areas
um where we know we have problems it
will also
um enable us to see where our need is
for Coastal parking and Town Center
Parking as well as future proof
ourselves that's my ideology
from this review fingers crossed it will
come out that way
councilor bright
yeah I was interested to uh to to hear
Simon's point Thank you again Simon
um on the around absence you've just
mentioned absence around the uh the
pockets of good practice that you have
identified
um
I'm assuming these pockets of good
practices are shared across the across
the organization
so that's all that's all clarifying
exactly where they are and rolled out
yes so in terms of our our um
uh day-to-day manual procedure manual
we've actually shared that and following
this audit with some of my other teams
which are there taking on board and so
some of the ways that they work on daily
tasks and things so yes it's shared
great thank you and we use our managers
forum for that as well
okay members if there's no other points
we are asked on here to receive the
report and to agree the changes to the
2023-24 internal audit plan resulting
from changes in perceived risk detailed
at 0.5 of annex one of the attachment
report uh can I have a proposer and a
second to please
yep councilor Garner proposing councilor
britcher seconding is that agreed
members great okay moving on to agenda
item 10 internal audit annual report
2022-23 Christine over to you
thank you chair
members if I could direct you please to
page 343.
this sets out
um the purpose of this report so as
alluded to in the training session
earlier
the
um
previous four meetings of the committee
are summarized at the year end and to
take that higher helicopter view of what
all this means and why all these
individual pieces of work add up to
something
um again mentioning our Professional
Standards we have to provide an opinion
on the overall of adequacy and
effectiveness of the council's internal
control environment
present a summary of the work undertaken
to form that opinion
draw attention to any issues that we
judge particularly relevant to the
preparing preparing of the annual
governance statement in an ideal world
that item would follow this but but
we've we've heard that already this
evening
compare the actual order audit activity
with that which was planned what we
promised you last March on why that
changed and summarized the performance
of the internal audit against its
criteria
and to comment on the compliance with
our public sector internal audit
standards and the results of our quality
assurance
and very very importantly has drawn
attention to in the training to confirm
that we have acted without
influence or been restricted in in our
carrying out law on our responsibilities
so the report members is really in two
parts
um clearly we need to address
um how internal audit has performed and
those
metrics are set out on paragraphs 3.1 to
3.7 the reports pages 346.
and they are important metrics as
someone's just taken you through the
balance scorecard in the previous item I
won't go into a great detail but that
dashboard is summarized for the year in
in appendix 4 for you
arguably the the more important part of
the report is really
um so what in terms of measuring
Management's response to the individual
findings in those pieces of work that
we've undertaken and if I could take you
then to page 347 of the report a
paragraph four that starts to set out
the overview
and we've provided three views of of the
summary of the work in paragraph 4.1 we
show a summary of the risks that we've
identified so all of those individual
recommendations that we've um raised in
the action plans of all the work that
was concluded
and this is summarized and split out
between the critical the high the medium
and the low priority risks in those
tables
the second view in 4.2 is the assurances
that we've given as Simon is highlighted
at the conclusion of each piece of work
we identify an individual Assurance
level
and these reflect where we have split
opinions
um these reflect the lower one in this
summary here
and taken together I think
um it's really important to see there's
there's been a change in the trend for
the year looking back the 42 percent of
the reviews were in the substantial or
reasonable Assurance
um Arena and there was an unprecedented
number of no and lower Assurance levels
in that year
also it's important throughout this
report I should have highlighted earlier
um as thanet District Council is the
host for East Kent Services majority of
which Osama has already explained is
what the work undertaken by civica for
you
um the the results of our work for East
Kent services are also shown in each of
these and the appendices include the
Eastern Services annual report
and there are no areas of concern for me
to highlight to the committee in those
reports so the phone with you and and we
we will come back to this each each time
is the so what in terms of the results
of our follow-up and I apologize for the
layout of the table there when it left
me those words weren't quite split but
no Assurance limited reasonable or been
some squished
um
so the conclusion of the follow-up and I
think this is important also I'd like to
sort of mention as as the chair has
already mentioned when we have done with
these technology partnership we'll
undertake one follow-up for the
committee for the council and at the
point when they haven't progressed or
they are critical or high
recommendations as there was in the item
before this is the point at which we're
escalating them to committee and is
where we're flagging you know this is
the areas you might like to ask for a
future progress report one
so you've picked that up which is really
really essential
so in this table we can see that there
were four areas
um after follow-up that had no or
limited assurance
and I can update the committee with um
the table there the street cleansing uh
we actually would commissioned then to
undertake a further follow-up and that
was reported to our March meeting and
where the opinion was changed to limited
and we had um the service manager
responsible gave a great a detailed
update on what had happened and what was
yet to happen in in those areas
and similarly for uh commercial lab
properties and concessions we've already
talked about rents leases
um this evening we also had a detailed
presentation by the asset manager at the
March I think it was March meeting where
he presented
um again what the plan is how it how
it's being addressed and what resources
are required to be to deliver so there
were two areas and as you go through the
report you'll see that the East Kent
sorry the equality and diversity and the
thanet community Lotto were at limited
and
um consequently there may be areas that
you would ask for further progress
report during the year
or at least to understand whether those
critical and high risk recommendations
have been implemented
moving through the report
um
um I think it's probably just useful to
present page 355 appendix 2 and so I'm
going to explained how that table works
and clearly there were changes to the
plan during the year and this summarizes
the original days the revised days and
the actual at the year-end position
so all of those individual pieces work
is what leads us to um the opinion
uh in the training I think I've alluded
to us trying to align our opinion
alongside the changes with Grant
Thornton's external audit opinion and
their value for money opinion where they
provide three views and they're looking
at corporate governance risk management
internal control separately so we've
also last year was the first year that
we undertook to do that it's kind of
work in progress but we have done that
again and paragraph 5.1
um you know it's not an opinion that I
would have easily we would have been
expecting to write or wanted to write in
this year it's
formed from as we've said factual
evidence-based individual pieces of work
um but at the end of the day it's it's a
subjective view but until some of these
areas start to embed and we can say
they're consistently effectively applied
we I can only conclude that there is
lower confidence in these areas
similarly with internal control as
highlighted just recently in the table
was summarizing the opinions there have
been a higher number of the lower level
of opinions in in the individual pieces
of work and there are 10 reviews that we
are yet to follow up due to the timing
of these that are listed in the table in
5.2 and they're likely due date for
those follow-ups to have been undertaken
they will be presented to a future
meeting of the committee and similarly
if the committee were concerned over any
progress in those areas there would be
ones that you might like to ask for
further follow-up or further updates
um again it's kind of unprecedented and
you will have read the report so I won't
go through
um in further detail other than the same
5.3 we are confident and you will see
this the risk register the risk process
the processes are sound and effective
week due to uh review that as an
internal audit I believe yeah next year
or the area after but we can conclude
that the risk management processes are
effective in working
given
[Music]
um
that
[Music]
um
it is a backward look this is a report
that is only up to the 31st of March and
given the nature of the conclusion and
the opinion
um when it was presented to management
team it was felt appropriate for
management to be able to provide a
response to the report and that is set
out in paragraph six
with the view to to
contextualize some of those things and
the reasons behind why we've had why
internal audit have found what we have
found during the year
um and also I think to
reaffirm the commitment that it is in
the final paragraph there in terms of
presenting a more positive opinion by
the time we had this meeting this time
next year members
um I think in terms of presentation
that's probably enough for me obviously
very happy to take any questions or if
the section 151 officer needs to to come
in as well thank you
thank you very much Christine Chris did
you want to come in and have anything
thank you thank you chair
um and thank you Christine
um as Christine set out
um at section 6 reports the management
response to it
um it's been well reported that the
council's had issues with its corporate
governance
um particularly around the disciplinary
and grievance Arena the corporate
management team and we've made good
progress with that and implementing the
recommendations of the independent
monitoring officer and the external
Auditors stash recommendations however
um
nonetheless we we had a big turnover in
Senior Management staff and that put a
real strain on the corporate management
team ability to address
some of the recommendations that were
put in place at pretty much the whole
well not pretty much the whole top tier
of the organizations management team did
leave in a very short space of time was
replaced and we're we're still in the
process of recruiting to the last couple
of posts within our corporate management
team I think there's only two left that
we need to fill
across directors and heads of service
once we've done that
what we've already made progress and
once we've got that complete we'll be
much better resource than in a position
to actually address these and as
Christine said we are fully committed to
implementing these recommendations the
as Penny button said they are very much
welcomed officers want to have clean
audit reports but when they don't come
forward we take those recommendations
and when we accept them we
we want clearly to implement them as
soon as possible but there have been
some things that have been difficult to
do than at Lottery taking that as an
example is just one where there's not
been the resources to do it it's not one
something that's high up on our
corporate plan in terms of a priority
and we've just not had the uh bandwidth
or capacity or space when the corporate
management team to address those given
the the turnover and staff and key
positions
thank you very much
um reflecting that Chris and bearing in
mind a lot of the committee knew
including myself to this if we were to
ask for the lotto and I think equality
and diversity of the two was it that you
mentioned Christine if we did ask for
them to be brought back with a further
report what would that look like because
bear in mind what you said about
um the prioritization on this there's
there's a balance we want to strike it
between doing our job of making sure the
recommendations from the internal
Auditors are reflected but we've also
not creating additional work for
officers on things that may not be a
priority I think I'm looking at the
committee I think we would want to make
sure that this isn't lost
but reflecting that fact so what would
that process look like in terms of a
quality diversity inclusion I wouldn't
want to diminish that in any shape or
form that is an important priority for
us we've been discussing that at
corporate management team and where
um that policy sits both internally
within our own staff cohort and in terms
of how we engage with our community and
wireless stakeholders I feel like we're
making progress with that and we'd be in
a position to report back to the
committee
um perhaps not September certainly
November need to speak to Christine
around programming of that work
I'd be concerned speaking candidly and
just frankly if we if we programmed in a
lottery one
um how much progress would be made in
the immediate term but certainly it's
something that needs addressing and
again I'd need to speak to colleagues in
the corporate management team and also
to Christine Parker to understand
um when an appropriate and Optimum time
would be to to plan a review of that
that piece of work okay thank you
because I guess as a as an audit
committee we have two levers here the
first lever is to ask you to come back
and give us a monitoring report second
one is to refer this up I certainly
don't feel unless any members have any
strong user at that point of referring
up but I think it would be good if in
November we could receive even a status
report on both of them even if that's to
say on the lotto side nothing has
happened however we have had discussions
and it looks like it'll be picked up in
2024. our members
broadly happy with that yeah do you want
to say anymore Chris
um yes I'm in November I'm happy to do
so without
um putting some error on it and any
pressure here as our interim monitoring
officers
um Samira you're due to be with us till
um November time so I don't want to put
any pressure on I don't know if uh you
will be here when we have the committee
but I don't want to put too much
pressure on Samir to deliver and we've
got a new permanent monitoring officer
joining us at the end of October so
there may be some we can find a
statement I just don't know how again
because of the the change in Staffing
how much progress will be made but I
agree
um a
um I think reporting up to cabin at this
moment I would be premature and welcome
the opportunity to bring an update
report can I suggest then if there is
substantial updates that this is
included on the agenda if there are only
informal updates that before around that
time members are all emailed with an
update so there is no point in having a
vendor item but there's not a lot to
discuss but I think we'd all want to
make sure that this is kept on the radar
so okay there was also another issue
Christine that um councilor town he
raised earlier around from property
rents and use of Assets Now I sort of
shoved this later in the agenda because
I felt from looking at some of the work
that you've done in the last year of
looking at some of these areas
would it be and again the last committee
meeting I think approved next year's
program
are you as part of the next 12 months
worth of work anticipating any audits
around this area that we could
potentially tie that discussion into
[Music]
um yes and it's an interesting
um
example of how we're tolerating the
risks until such time as you have news
that you can be assured that
everything's working and it's it's it's
sometimes that lag can be longer well
unfortunately you've lost the continuity
in the sense that we did the audit in
response to the audit the manager came
forward at the point where it was still
limited after follow-up and gave that
presentation I think it was the last
meeting was March I I'll check when when
that was but it was a the detailed
presentation
um was uh addressing all of the areas
that we'd raised in the audit and it
went broad more broader to respond to a
bigger Asset Management plan and what
the council's doing which others
colleagues can probably give you a
better update
um so we aren't planning to do anything
more in the next but you as a committee
um I feel we were talking about the
recommendations tracker weren't we in at
the briefing in terms of you need to
understand how many critical or high
risks have we escalated I mean in the
year there were 35 and you probably as a
committee want to know well how many of
those have been since implemented and
that's the kind of information I think
is useful
to bring back
there's a piece of work to be done about
how who is doing those reviews of of
effectively
risks that we've been escalated that are
in stasis until you close them down as a
committee so I think that that's a
useful uh way to respond to those but in
terms of us telling you what we're
already telling you you're not
benefiting we're all about trying to add
value as we said we don't have enough
resources to audit everything every year
so we're trying to go into fresh areas
rather than come back and keep reviewing
what we've already told you to do if
that makes sense as well
so councilor towning I think there's
clearly an issue that's been flagged up
there I'm not 100 certain whether asking
the officer to come and ask questions
because
if if we're focusing on process we've
already had a audit that's flagged up
the issues of management it's dealing
with them the some of the issues you're
raising are probably much better dealt
with either at cabinet or via overview
and scrutiny I will however because I'm
not familiar enough with the issue if
you're happy I will take that as an
action away with Chris to speak about
that and work out whether that could be
factored into a future agenda item or
whether it's better dealt with elsewhere
do you want to come in Council towning
yep thank you for that uh I fully agree
that uh asking Christine
and decided to look at the portfolio and
giving us a good insight to the critical
or the overall view as to how where we
stand with regards to exposure but uh
what I truly I understand is that we did
have uh Mike mark
uh peace come here and talk to us about
with the Bob Porter
we have now an opportunity where we have
Andrea plant who has been in the Estates
Apartment for quite a while
she is now in charge of it
and she is putting together a a review
of it and maybe it would be a good idea
to understand how that review is going
to work and give yourselves also an
understanding of how that review is
going to work to give us a clearer
picture of where we're traveling because
we we don't know where we're traveling
there'll be heavy note for quite a long
while thank you
are you happy that we can take that away
and just come back to you with a way
forwards just because I don't think on
the hoof we'd want to make a decision on
that Chris do you want to come in at all
on that just before we move on yeah uh
thank you
um just in terms again contacts this
year's budget
um we've put an extra 625
000 pounds into the property and Estates
team
um for additional Staffing roles and the
the intention was that would be fully
funded from an increase in rental income
um so before the next meeting if I've
got my committee titled right in my head
cabinet will have the first quarterly
update on the budget monitoring position
for the year
in September so there there will be
we'll be able to appreciate doesn't come
to this committee but the members will
start to have sight of how that is
progressing
um over and above that 625 in terms of
Staffing establishment we also put 800
000 into the budget as well to allow for
repairs and maintenance backlog to be
addressed across our portfolio so
um I would just my only concern again I
think as I said earlier any presentation
that we get Andrea planting to do should
be focused on process and uh in terms of
how how those rent reviews will be
undertaken rather than any detailed sort
of
um investigation or scrutiny of
properties per se which would be better
served by overview and scrutiny
I'll pick up I'll pick this up um cancer
towning and see if we can work out a way
where members can get informed on this
but potentially make sure it's in the
right committee so yeah
um I've got a couple of questions before
I go into any member have any uh yes
counselor Ghana
yeah thank you yeah I'd just like to
thank Chris Dean and the team for the
report
and for the work I understand I'm sort
of focusing here on Section 5.1 the
corporate governance section because I'm
aware as one of the two councilors who
were here over the last four years I'm
quite aware of the the work they did to
bring some of these governance issues to
the fore to enable us to then go on and
tackle them and get to the position
we're in now so thank you for that and
one of the one of the
items that's mentioned in there
um is the lack of a formal project
management framework and the review that
was deferred because there was the um
post implementation review of project
birth four and five
um so see we know there's there's a
number of very significant projects
going to be starting kicking off if they
haven't already
um in various areas around Planet
especially at the Port so I'll be Keen
to know when we are going to get a
review of that project management
process so as we can be assured that the
process we're following is going to
enable
a successful implementation of any of
these projects
thank you Christine thank you chair the
recommendations from the piece of work
that was undertaken on birth four five
uh were broader than just that
particular project and
um
going back to the training earlier we
were talking about the first line of
defense and the second line of defense
this is the second line of defense where
is the project management methodology
the framework that everything else that
hang off that said the council is
clearly delivering projects so you know
officers running those projects are
using their own methodologies and some
of those projects that deliver very
successfully
so in terms of
um this is this is probably the point
we're trying to make I was trying to
make in this uh the next paragraph you
know operationally things are working
quite well on the on the coal face and
officers are delivering what has been
missing when we've undertaking the
reviews in lot in terms of governance
it's this structure and the process of
the strategies and the policies being up
to date visible easily accessible and
and those kind of observations in terms
of governance
um I'm due to undertake the follow-up to
those recommendations so I say whilst
they're very specific from that piece of
work that was undertaken from birth or
five they were more generic in terms of
these things that management need to
address I don't Mr blunder wants to come
in and give a progress report because he
was briefing me earlier that on what has
already been undertaken but but I will
be bringing the progress report back to
a future committee when that's
undertaken thank you
thank you um thank you Christine and um
if I may just say as well thank
Christine because we we have been
discussions about this and one of the
things Christine spoke about the
benefits of the East Kent audit
partnership is that they they see an
insight into the operations not just at
thanet but across the partnership and
actually
um
in the discussions that Christine and
I've been having she shared the project
management framework that they've got in
place in Dover that's just one that
we've been looking at um in terms of
we've um we're reviewing another project
manager Frameworks that are new other
authorities across Kent that's been
shared between myself uh Mike cumber Bob
Porter and Colin uh Carmichael leader
I'm not the leader excuse me the chief
executive is leading on that project
um in terms of overviewing and updating
our project management framework we I
would expect that we will get this
resolved
um
fairly rapidly now but there are lots of
the lots of different aspects of it that
come into as well as I referred to
earlier we're undertaking a procurement
review and that's just one part of it
procurement
um is a key aspect of project management
we're also looking at
the contract management side of one of
the councilors on the committee referred
to I think it may have been councilor
Nichols around the the lease
leasing arrangement of the capacity and
legal team I know Samira is looking at
ensuring that we've got adequate
resource is in place for contract
management so sorry that's a bit bitty
and fragmented because there are it
touches lots of different aspects of the
council there are good
um examples of good practice across the
organization and we've brought in
other officers to discuss this at
corporate management team where it said
outside the corporate management team
who are experts in project management to
um effectively advise us and it share
that best practice that is happening
because we have seen a number of
projects well managed we just need to
take the best parts of that from inside
the council and also outside the council
and come up something consistent and
coherent that we can apply across the
whole organization so easier said than
done it's work in progress but it's
something that's right at the top of
corporate management team's to-do list
and priority lists at the moment
thank you Chris uh councilor bright
yeah I was just going to come in on the
point on page 352 where they uh where
Christine's report mentions that there
have been occasions during the year
where our work has been hampered due to
difficulties in gaining responses from
management
um
I guess obviously we all understand the
importance of audit and the importance
of making sure we're facilitating
Christine and the team's ability to
carry out their jobs
um
I'm making an assumption that's due to
kind of capacity issues in the past but
I mean are we putting steps in place to
mitigate against that in future
um yeah absolutely in terms of the
management response
um
that has that is due to capacity issues
um myself included in that
um Christine and I have
um increased uh the as a response in
part response to this the frequency that
we'll be meeting we'll have regular
meeting set up to discuss this that will
allow
um me to escalate any sort of issues
prior to
um them you know them going to the
corporate management team so that's one
of the tools that we'll be looking at
doing as well as obviously inviting uh
Christine to our corporate management
team on a quarterly basis
kick you
thank you very much and Christine I had
to just two quick questions
um I know on page page 356 that the
business continuity Emergency Management
audit was deferred can I just confirm
that's due to come back in the next year
because obviously that's come up a
couple of times in our discussion around
the risk the importance of business
continuity Emergency Management I just
wanted to understand whether that's been
picked up soon
thank you it wasn't one of the ones that
was then reintroduced into the 2324 plan
based on the risk profile of it at the
time and
um
largely in response to a lot of the
covid emergency it was one of the areas
that was pushed back because it had been
operated so many times during that time
um so it will be reconsidered from
December onwards to whether it comes
forward again to next year's plan and if
it's still an area of concern then
clearly that's partly why we also
consult the committee on what's in the
plan if they've got concerns if they
fill this gaps in the plan but it it
wasn't brought from 23 into 24 sorry
thank you okay and just out of interest
and you can maybe get the information
after you don't have it to hand do you
know what the last Assurance was around
business continuity emergency planning
again you don't have to answer now this
is a thank you I would need to check
it's it's it's at fingertip reach but I
haven't got it in directly in front of
me so I can easily if you could just you
know if you get a chance you might be
interested in that
um and the other one again other members
may know more about this but it keeps
popping up East Kent opportunities
um
it came up at full Council as well
um and I guess I'm just looking for
guidance from the offices on this it's
come up here as having no Assurance is
this something that the committee should
be interested in following up on are
there plans to audit this I recognize
there's commercial sensitivities there
but I want to make sure we're doing our
due diligence that this is coming up
quite a few times yeah thank you chair
um it is actually so it's a live order
at the moment it's near it's nearing
um its conclusion it will be coming to
the committee at its next meeting
thank you very much do any other members
have questions or comments
okay um recommendation is that members
note the opinion of the head of audit
partnership and that members receive the
annual report detailing the work of the
ekap and its performance to underpin the
2022-23 opinion clever proposer and the
second please
councilor townies proposed councilor
bright has seconded
do members agree
right we're nearly there folks last two
stick with us so agenda item 11 updated
are we is it Ripper policy yeah okay
agenda item 11 updated Ripper policy
2023 over to you Samira
thank you chair it's essentially the
updated Ripper policy which stands for
regulation of investigatory powers under
the 2000 Act
surveillance is defined in the section
26-2 of the reaper obviously I don't
expect everybody to remember that which
is fine it set out under page 364 of the
report and the updated policy actually
starts from page 371 of the report
members asked to know that it is Council
policy not to exercise the available
powers under the Ripple unless it's
absolutely necessary
most of the council surveillance is over
to eye open and not covert so we don't
actually do any hidden covert however
there have been occasions in the past
few years the authorization have been
given for direct surveillance but I can
confirm that our records shows which is
what I have reported to the commissioner
that there's been no covert surveillance
for the year 2022 and 2023 so far
members may be called some of you may
recall that this report this policy did
um arrive at Uni committee last year at
this time
and he was endorsed by by the committee
however as the policies required to be
updated every year the report before
USAF is an updated version with all the
updated forms for cover surveillance
which are set out in the appendix to the
report and it starts from page four head
under downwards
members also asked to note that the
council had this last inspection by the
commissioner in April 2022.
which resulted in a number of
recommendations which are outlined and
starts from page 365 of the report
I'm pleased to confirm and there's a
report there's a latter times to the
report from the commissioner confirming
that all the recommendations have been
endorsed and been achieved by the
council including all the training and
all for all development offices
including the CMT members and Senior
officers
the council also now has have a center
record for all authorization with a
timetable for destruction in line with
policy which was quite crucial and was
one of the recommendations from the
commissioner
members of the DNA committee are asked
to adopt the amended policy as I thought
in appendix one of the berry War note
and sign of the ipco which is the
investigatory power commissioner office
letter the two letters attached one is
the regional recommendation and the
second one where he signs off the
recommendation
um and then lastly no dictivity set out
during the year which at the moment is
none
happy to take any questions
thank you Samira and um as has been in
without apologies to members of the
table on pages three six five three six
eight in the original agenda had some
formatting issues so you couldn't read
it are there any comments or questions
from any members on this
nope okay as Samira set out the
recommendation can I please have a
proposer and a second please have a
proposal
councilor Butcher and a seconder
councilor Donaldson our members agreed
here we are final agenda item 12 annual
treasury management review 2022-23 this
always gets left to the end and there
are very rarely questions so let's see
we'll follow that Trend over to you
Chris
thank you and we did discuss about where
we'll schedule this on the agenda in
future
in addition we are going to arrange for
some training for members on Treasury
management we have um external treasury
management advisors who provide advice
to myself and Matt on how we manage our
treasury activities and they'll come in
and provide some face-to-face training
for members to appreciate this is quite
a technical subject area
treasury management is it's not about
our budgets it's not about what we're
spending on Services it's all about how
we manage the cash that's coming through
the council every year so as I kind of
alluded to in the training it's about
100 million that flow through our bank
account every year
on top of that we hold
borrowing as well in terms of debt so I
won't go through the whole report it's
been a long meeting so I promise you
I'll keep this as short and as Snappy as
possible so just looking trying to pull
some key things out of the exact summary
for a start so you'll see sip for that's
the chartered Institute of Public
Finance and accountancy they've been
referred to a couple of times tonight
this is their definition of Treasury
Management on page 427
treasury management is the management of
the local authorities borrowing
Investments and cash flows it's banking
money market and Capital Market
transactions so borrowing pretty
self-explanatory similar to what you
would see would borrow from other
institutions typically we borrow from
something called the Public Works loan
board pwlb they're a mom of government
that allow us to borrow money for them
cash flows that's the money that comes
in and out banking we bank with
it's been a long night
who used to be Lloyd's
[Applause]
um
yeah we've not yeah I'll shut up I can't
even come back on that one
um
uh money market transactions and Capital
Market transactions we'll cover that in
the training but if anyone's got any
specific questions I'm happy to answer
those an effective control of the risks
associated with those activities and
that again is a theme that we've heard
coming through tonight's
um not only the the meeting and the
training and I must say I'm very
appreciative of members time and
attention and what's been a very lengthy
evening in pursuit of Optum for
performance consistent with those risks
so what are some of the key items coming
out of that
um the gross debt also called a
borrowing position as at the end of
March last year was just shy of 20
million so we had 20 million of debts
that we'd taken on borrowing from other
institutions mainly the pwlb
um
we'd actually needed to borrow during
that time or the depth that we should
have held was about 52 million pounds
we'd met that short through for through
our own internal cash flows because at
the end of the year we had 60 million
pounds so if that's were using that
money instead of going to the bank to
save it whether that's Lords or NatWest
um again uh there's a very lengthy
report it's quite a standard format if
you were to look at this across uh not
just TDC but any other local Authority
there this is a statue report we have to
produce in order to comply with
regulations it'll also as well as being
coming to this meeting or go to Cabinet
in September and then be recommended on
to council so members get sort of three
bites of the charity ask questions and
scrutinize uh this our treasury
management activity for the last year
going backwards
um it's a lot of detail in a report
perhaps something that will be of
interest if we go on to
Page Six
for
um the report on page 436 you'll see
that chart which has gone up and up and
up and up that's interest rates no news
to anyone but borrowings become a lot
more expensive over the 12 months so at
the start of the financial year
borrowing rates below one percent and
now uh even for the council uh it costs
us over four percent to borrow at the
end of the financial year what we know
since then we've had further increases
in the base rate subsequently what you
may be interested to see on the bottom
of page
438 so reference link group this is
their forecast or where they think
interest rates are going to go their
forecast is that interest rates will
start to fall but we already know that
they're higher than where they were
um and they're probably in June and
they're probably likely to go further up
again I think the current forecasts are
at six percent because of where
inflation has been quite so sticky so
it's really really treasure management
is a really difficult thing to get right
you can't predict really what's going to
happen who knew what was going to happen
with interest rates all you can do is
just try and take risk informed
decisions in general we've got a very
very low risk appetite in terms of our
investment strategy we stick most of our
cash in Money Market funds which are
about as boring and investment type as
you can get means we can get the money
back instant access
their yields are a little bit lower than
if we tied it down for a year or so but
one of the benefits of us not tying our
money down is that we've benefited from
these instant increases in the base rate
if we've been tying our money down for
one two three years back a year or so
ago when the rates were so low we
wouldn't have seen those increases in
interest rates that's all I'm going to
say on the item because it's incredibly
late and you've already had a very long
agenda to get through but I'm happy to
take any questions if there are any on
this item thank okay
thank you I would just add one comment
um I'm I think at times we will try and
bring this agenda item forward because
it does always get left at the end it is
quite important and I would just give
one sort of story from when I was on
Kent County Council before when we used
to deal with treasury the one thing we
were talking about was the fact that the
Icelandic Banks had collapsed and Kent
County Council had all sorts of problems
and that was directly related to
treasury strategy so it is important
because I think it's same same reason
Ken came to council it was end of the
agenda and then suddenly you had cabinet
members on TV and the world's media sort
of descending on organizations that got
caught out so it's important so we may
well look at bringing this forward to
early in the agenda in the future is
anybody sorry chair for me just in terms
of that
um so this is a backwards look the next
time you'll see this will be the
forwards look and that will be setting
out our strategy which includes the
types of Institutions and what is called
counterparties that we will invest in
and as you say that would be the type of
thing where'd you say will you be
willing to invest in Iceland or parts of
the Middle East or yeah or you know
tobacco and all those types of things
and that is where the committee has the
opportunity to ask those questions
councilor manners
thank you I'll be really brief because
at the risk of making myself even more
unpopular
um on the issue of um being risk-averse
uh great
um but will any of the reserves
um be invested in tdc's own property
assets given that there's going to be a
substantial repair bill on many of those
assets in order to provide a return and
perhaps a better return that might be
available on any of any of the markets
at the moment
um so this year we did put 800 000 into
the budget we'll review progress with
that
um in terms of the cash so there's 60
million that we're holding that's not
all just our cash some of that is
um yeah thank you HRA balances money
that we've received in council tax that
we then in due course pay over to the
County Council part of our working cash
flow so not all of that 60 million
it's available for us to spend on those
purposes
um but we'll be looking at that more as
part of our budget strategy rather than
our treasury management strategy because
that's how we spend money on our
services and our assets where this is
how we would invest that cash
thank you very much uh councilor town
I've already touched the subject with
you about your boring
capability for the future
Matt says that all the time it's fine I
can't resist asking you questions you
see
I'm going to drop you a line about the
um
take on board
in respect of the um
program of affordable housing it's
fairly substantial looking at the cost
of money today is something that we need
to actually understand better in this
treasury report hopefully the next time
around thank you I'll copy uh chair into
any other comments from anyone
okay so recommendation is that we note
the actual 2022-23 Prudential and
treasury indicates in this report we
make comments as appropriate and that we
recommend this report to council for a
for approval can I please have a
proposer and a secondary
Council Deborah proposed accounts the
bright seconded
are we agreed members okay
um you will be pleased to hear that that
concludes tonight's proceedings can I
thank the internal audit officers for
attending and all other officers
um sorry apologies just perform members
counselor Mata face
okay I'm going to close the meeting
we'll pick that up thank you very much
officers for attending and for members
it's been an excellent meeting thank you
very much everyone